[Musique]
allô allô
tout le monde en parle ah le truc mais
oui ce matin je suis allé au pressing
mais attends mais tout le monde en parle
aussi lui aussi
c'est énorme je crois pas tout le monde
en parle le résultat mais tout le monde
en parle
à minuit samedi soir
bienvenue sur le plateau de Tout le
monde en parle vous connaissez le
principe tout le monde en parle alors
tout le monde en parle
vous connaissez Camille Olivier les
voici
je vous demande de vous arrêter je vous
demande de vous arrêter je vous demande
de vous arrêter bien alors mis à part
Kad et Olivier nous recevrons ce soir
Patrick Sébastien
Blade
vanessa Demouy
Bernard Laporte
Michel Houellebecq
et Christophe Hogard de l'équipe de
Calais
je vous demande de vous arrêter bon
alors dans quelques instants on sera en
duplex avec Londres en interviewera
Mohamed Al-Fayed qui est le père de dial
Fayed le fiancé de Lady qui a trouvé la
mort comme vous le savez le 30 août 1997
sous le pont de l'Alma et Mohamed El
Fayet donc le père de de dial Fayet
d'une croix pas du tout que ce soit un
accident il propose du tout que ça soit
le chauffeur qui était sous et tout ça
et lui il dit qu'un complot pourrait
assassiner son fils et sa future
belle-fille voilà donc on va discuter
avec lui il va nous apporter l'épreuve
de sa thèse voilà d'accord je pense
qu'on dira pas grand chose à ce
moment-là mais non on va l'écouter lui
on écoutera parce que c'est rare qu'il
fasse de la télé surtout en France on
sait qu'il y a une tradition dans cette
émission
avant de commencer l'émission on regarde
ce qui s'est passé de mieux la semaine
précédente
Taxi 3 c'est déjà écrit dans la tête de
Luc ouais c'est tranquille c'est un bon
boulot maintenant je crois que ça roule
quoi faut pas tomber dans le ridicule et
puis je crois que que Besson c'est un
mec qui a assez intelligent pour ça les
extraterrestres
quand on se fait serrer par les keufs
comme on dit on devient vite un arabe
voir un boulot grave tout de suite ah
ouais tu te retrouves
avec les autres travaux dans la cage
sans chaussettes et puis quand tu es
dans le car et qu'on t'amène à l'hôpital
pour voir si tu as rien que c'était pas
malade tu as une bonne rangée sur la
gueule et puis on me dit ça le bonniole
et ben voilà moi je suis habillé par la
Redoute mais je suis tranquille dans des
commissariat
la chose qui vous plaît le plus dans le
sexe
flirter est-ce qu'il vous plaît le moi
les trucs attachés ta race comme ça
vous faites vos affaires entre vous et
nos affaires de comportement que j'ai
envie que mon film déclenche
j'ai envie qu'on sorte des salles avec
des anges
alors ce qu'on voit dans votre film
c'est pas terrible
et l'amour Thierry labour est-ce que
vous êtes fait souvent fourré
[Applaudissements]
quoi
est-ce que vous aimez les turlutés dans
votre salle de bain c'est rare que sur
l'autre mais j'aimerais ça pouvoir le
faire vous et vous vous sur lutter
une traduction française qui est drôle
d'être sur lutter ici
Julie extraordinaire c'est la première
fois que je vois comme ça parce que vous
avez votre colle de veste et tout son
dessous là et c'est la première
vous avez jamais fumé de pétard vous
avez jamais tapé de garçons vous avez
jamais utilisé de godemichet non osez
beaucoup de choses à apprendre encore
qui fait la loi sur la terre
on peut presser sur la détente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était tout le monde en a parlé le best
of de la semaine dernière
[Applaudissements]
vous auriez dû venir pour Julie
Depardieu
extraordinaire
pouvait intervenir il y a pas de bien
alors Monsieur Al Fayed bonsoir merci
d'avoir accepté de répondre aux
questions de tout le monde en parle vous
êtes en compagnie de John McNamara qui
est votre directeur de la sécurité mais
avant de converser avec vous d'abord un
rappel des faits
[Musique]
donc sur cette affaire un jugement a été
rendu en septembre 1999 qui a conclu à
l'accident de voiture dû à l'alcoolémie
du chauffeur de la Mercedes Henri Paul
depuis le début vous monsieur le Fayette
vous n'y croyez pas et vous parlez de
complot de meurtre organisés par la
Couronne britannique aidée par les
services secrets anglais américain et
français et quel serait le mobile de ce
crime ou de ses crimes
de ce crime c'est un racisme absolu
la famille royale et les stablishment
dans ce pays
partout dans le monde
la personne et la personne qui
n'acceptera jamais mon fils entend
égyptien
parce qu'il faut bien voir que il
s'agissait du il aurait s'agit du
beau-père du futur roi d'Angleterre et
c'est ça la raison c'est ça le mobile
et la personne qui a organisé
qui organisait cela et qui a payé de sa
poche c'est le prince Philippe
lorsqu'il était enfant il a passé
beaucoup de temps en Allemagne
tout jeune
il y avait un mariage avec deux généraux
d'Hitler dans cette famille ça suffit
comme explication et cette personne a
grandi dans un environnement nazi
aurait été compromettant personne ne
sait vraiment
pourquoi et comment cela s'est passé
mais dans le pays en Angleterre la
presse vous appelle par exemple
l'égyptien ou le chèque d'Arabie bien
que vous soyez la 14e fortune du pays
vous êtes victime d'un certain racisme
mais il y avait aussi la la lutte de
Diana contre la cour d’angleterre elle
avait déclaré que Charles le roi
d'Angleterre le futur roi d'Angleterre
était incapable de gouverner et c'est
vrai que sur fond de crise monarchique
en Angleterre c'était un problème
d'ailleurs James Hewitt qui a été
l'amant de Lady Di a fait état de
menaces reçu par la princesse Diana et
on peut dire qu'il a il a rien à gagner
à révéler ça lui en tous les cas
oui c'est vrai on l'a vu du reste dans
d'autres programmes ou dans d'autres
interviews à la télévision c'est
exactement comme ça que ça s'est passé
cette femme a souffert pendant toute sa
vie de femme mariée
elle a souffert auprès du prince Charles
le prince Charles ne lui a apporté aucun
amour aucune vie de famille ne lui
apporter aucune attention à la vie V une
vie tout à fait atroce
[Musique]
on attendait un patiemment on attendait
un patiemment le livre du seul rescapé
de l'accident c'est le garde du corps
trevoris john's effectivement il avait
été rendu amnésique par l'accident
maintenant il a retrouvé la mémoire mais
malheureusement il se souvient plus des
10 minutes qui précèdent le drame du
pont de l'Alma elle se souvient même
plus de de l'itinéraire en revanche vous
démontrez qu'il ment dans son livre au
sujet de la bague offerte par votre fils
de dial Fayed à la princesse Diana et
ceci confirme votre opinion le garde du
corps trésoris Jones a été retourné par
des espions
j'avais l'oeil sur cette personne
pendant quatre mois
il a travaillé pour moi pendant 5 ans je
lui faisais confiance en tant que garde
du corps
du corps donc trois gardes du corps mon
quitté du jour au lendemain
dans le cadre de relation humaine
normale ça ne se ferait pas ignorer il y
aurait au moins une certaine gratitude
donc sans aucune raison ça s'est passé
comme ça du jour au lendemain
on a craint qu'il retrouve la mémoire
mais on sait très bien que Henri Paul
qui travaille pour le service c'est
secret britté qui a travaillé pendant
trois ans
a servi le MI6
parce que tout ça c'est très délicat à
toutes ces informations là donc vous
voyez on peut retourner les gens c'est
comme ça que ça s'est passé
le 30 août 1997 votre fils d'Audi vous a
annoncé ses fiançailles avec la
princesse Diana et ça aurait été
officialisé le 1er septembre de la même
année
trevorise Jones lui ni complètement il
dit c'est pas vrai ça n'a été qu'une
romance d'été hier
discutera de ses relations avec la
princesse Diana avec un garde du corps
on peut évidemment faire toutes les
suppositions ou toutes les hypothèses
que l'on veut
moi j'ai eu des rapports avec les médias
le délit télégraphié il y a des
centaines d'articles
qui portrait la folie
personne ne peut connaître l'effet
personne je peux savoir ce qui s'est
passé directement c'est mon fils moi
j'ai perdu mon fils et c'était un
complot monsieur le Fayet maintenant on
en arrive à un point très précis
trevorise Jones donc le garde du corps
dit a dit dans son livre que Dodi
al-faye de votre fils n'avait jamais
acheté de bagues pour la princesse Diana
or vous sur injection d'un tribunal
britannique vous avez obtenu une requête
auprès du joaillier qui s'appelle
Alberto reposi place et le joaillier a
produit non seulement une facture de la
bague datée du 30 août 1997 mais en plus
une vidéo où l'on voit votre fils de
dial Fayette qui entre dans le magasin
c'est
exacts il y a des mensonges il y a des
tissus de conneries les services secrets
ont fait dire des tas de choses à tout
le monde
et je voudrais que monsieur mcdamara
vous explique un petit peu les détails
parce que lui était responsable à
l'époque il va vous donner les détails
de ce qui s'est passé exactement à
propos de la bague et avec Alberto
ribosi on l'écoute
dans son livre a fait l'objet de
manipulation visant à prouver qu'il n'y
avait pas de fiançailles et bien il faut
bien savoir que trevoris Johns
ou Diana rentrer dans la bijouterie la
veille de l'accident fatal la réalité
c'est qu'ils sont allés faire du lèche
vitrine
du joaillier Alberto ils ont vu une
magnifique bague
c'est à Monaco en réalité ce qui s'est
passé à ce moment-là c'est que la bague
a été envoyée à Paris de dial Fayed a
récupéré la bague auprès de Alberto
le 30 août dans la soirée et très
mauvaise chose
aurait accompagné
de dial Fayet pour récupérer la bague
mais le livre est une manipulation
l'effet sont très distordus pour
démontrer que la bague merci vous voyez
ce que je veux dire on va on comprend
très bien monsieur mclamara on va passer
maintenant à d'autres points obscurs du
dossier sur lesquels je vous demanderai
d'intervenir très brièvement pour les
pour les préciser alors les autres
points obscur du dossier bah il y a
d'abord l'axe lors de l'accident du fils
de monsieur al Fayet de dial Fayed lui
il est mort sur le coup dans l'accident
mais la princesse Diana était encore
vivante après le choc elle avait une
hémorragie interne personne la
diagnostiquée et on a mis 100 minutes
pour l'amener à l'hôpital est-ce que
vous pensez que il y a eu de la part des
urgentistes qui s'en sont occupés soit
une faute involontaire soit une faute
volontaire mais de mon père
[Musique]
alors on s'est demandé d'où venait ce
monoxyde de carbone les analyses de
contre-expertise ont été refusés pendant
48 heures on se demande aujourd'hui s'il
monoxyde de carbone n'était pas contenu
dans les airbags de la Mercedes est-ce
que vous croyez à ça
c'est très simple notre expert au
Royaume-Uni et un autre expert à
Lausanne en Suisse ont démontré que ce
niveau de monoxyde de carbone
n'aurait pas pu se trouver dans le sang
de Henri Paule notamment lorsqu'il
devait être ivre c'est vrai vous avez
raison il n'aurait pas pu marcher ni
même conduire évidemment l'explication
qui a étonnée par
les médecins français toxicologues et le
professeur Lacombe c'est que
le monoxyde de carbone aurait pu aurait
certainement pu venir des airbags et que
Henri Paul l'aurait inhalé
maintenant qu'il a été mort sur le coup
il n'a pas eu le temps de respirer
Mercedes Benz nous ont dit que les
airbags ne contiennent pas de monoxyde
de carbone
aucun expert pathologiste français ne
peut expliquer la présence du monoxyde
de carbone dans le sang d'Henri Paul
c'est impossible ce n'était pas son sang
et aujourd'hui
nous n'avons pas la possibilité
d'examiner de faire des analyses qui
sont toujours détenues par les Français
et les Français refusent catégoriquement
de laisser nos experts indépendants
accéder aux échantillons pour faire des
essais indépendants merci alors autre
point obscur du dossier c'est la façon
dont a travaillé la police française
l'enquête n'a pas été menée d'après vous
très correctement d'abord le lieu de
l'accident n'a pas été préservé par la
police ensuite il y a une Fiat Uno
blanche qui a été vu par septémoins qui
n'a pas été véritablement recherchée et
on n'a jamais parlé non plus de la moto
suiveuse qui aurait fait une queue de
poisson enfin bien chercher cette moto
suivieuse qui aurait fait une queue de
poisson à la Mercedes conduite par Henry
Paul alors est-ce que sur le la Uno
blanche par exemple est-ce que vous de
votre côté vous avez des informations
étaient un Vietnamien cette voiture
a été testée par la police française des
échantillons de la peinture de la Fiat
ont été mis encore correspondance avec
la peinture que l'on a retrouvé sur la
Mercedes cette voiture
à l'arrière ça a été confirmé ça et ça a
été confirmé par les témoins de l'époque
il y a des
examens qui confirment que cette voiture
correspond bien
celle ayant participé à la collision
cependant on s'en est arrêté là la
police
et les magistrats responsables de
l'enquête s'en sont arrêtés là alors que
à mon avis la voiture a été trouvée mais
on a arrêté là alors il y a deux points
qui militent effectivement pour la
théorie de Monsieur alfayette c'est
d'abord effectivement la bague puisque
cette bague a bien été achetée c'est une
bague dis-moi oui qui a bien été acheté
chez Alberto reposi part de dial Fayette
pour ses fiançailles avec la princesse
Diana et il y a une autre information
qui vous a été transmise monsieur
alfayette très récemment par votre
avocat parisien un juge français a fait
une requête auprès des ambassades
américaines et anglaises car on pense
que le numéro 2 des services secrets
MI6 était présent à Paris dans la nuit
du 30 août 1997
c'est juste c'est exact
en effet le numéro 2 du MI6
que ferait le numéro 2
m et 6 à Paris
on se le demande
Richard spyman et il y avait un autre
nom
Nicolas
se sont-ils rendus à Paris 3 semaines
avant la tragédie personne ne sait
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas en train
finalement de mener toute cette
opération d'abord parce que c'est tout à
fait naturel mais aussi parce que en
tant que propriétaire du Ritz vous êtes
l'employeur de Henri Paul le chauffeur
et donc la Couronne britannique ou la
famille Spencer la famille de Lady Di
peut se retourner contre vous pour vous
attaquer
se rendre à bien compte de la situation
sans les services français les services
secrets britanniques n’auraient jamais
perpétré ce meurtre
et j'espère que la Cour d'appel
fera la justice
parce que la France est un grand pays
moi j'ai beaucoup investi j'aime la
France et j'ai un domicile en France
donc je n'accepte pas cette situation et
j'espère véritablement que la Cour
d'appel rendra justice de moi et
moi je suis père
endeuillé je suis un individu qui aime
la France j'emploie un grand nombre de
personnes en France et je ne veux pas
être traité en France comme j'ai été
traité dans ce pays monsieur le Fayet de
dernière question on vous reproche de
faire tout ça aussi par vengeance contre
la famille d'Angleterre parce que vous
êtes la 14e fortune du pays en
Grande-Bretagne et vous n'arrivez pas à
obtenir la nationalité britannique this
island
non je veux pas me venger je n'ai pas
d'esprit de vengeance je suis un père
endeuillé par le décès de son fils tout
père qui aime son fils ferait exactement
la même chose que moi j'ai la certitude
que mon fils a été assassiné avec la
princesse Diana et les services secrets
français ont participé et ce crime et
ils sont les criminels principaux ayant
contribué à aider les services secrets
britanniques et j'espère que les
Français entendront bien cela parce que
cela pourrait bien se reproduire ça peut
toucher quelqu'un d'autre qui vit en
France il ne faut pas accepter cela
merci beaucoup de m'avoir donné la
possibilité d'expliquer la vérité merci
sur la disparition de mon fils et la
princesse Diana merci encore
accordé cette interview en exclusivité
merci beaucoup monsieur le Fayet merci
Monsieur mclamare bien entendu les
affirmations de Monsieur al Fayette
concernant tant le passé de la famille
royale d'Angleterre que l'affaire
elle-même ne constitue que sa propre
version des faits à ce jour même si des
interrogations subsistent aucun rapport
officiel ou expertise sérieux n'est venu
les confirmer la cour d'appel se
prononcera définitivement dans deux mois
sur les causes de l'accident
bien on continue vous l'avez connu
imitateur vous l'avez connu animateur le
voici réalisateur et acteur voici
Patrick Sébastien
les révélations de Mohamed Al Fayed au
sujet de la mort de la princesse Diana
et de son fils de dial Fayette façon
vous les accidents de Mercedes ça vous
connaît
un jour vous êtes un jour vous êtes du
côté de Vierzon et vous écoutez une
cassette et à un moment on sait pas
pourquoi la radio passe par-dessus la
cassette et vous entendez une voix
c'était peut-être radio Vierzon radio
Vierzon vous dit
attention et des orages et 10 minutes
plus tard aquaplaning vous vous plantez
en Mercedes j'ai fait un beau volcané
j'ai un très bon souvenir de ça parce
que normalement je dois crever quoi
c'était à 4 mètres en l'air ça je fais
100000 bornes par an donc il faut que ça
arrive
j'étais sur le bord du fossé j'avais la
gueule éclatée j'étais ouvert j'ai
encore la cicatrice ici j'étais cassé de
partout je saignais et il y a un mec qui
s'est arrêté qui m'a fait Patrick
Sébastien merde j'ai pas mon appareil
photo
ça fait toujours plaisir
je te jure il y a une autre histoire de
voiture avec Sébastien qui est assez
extraordinaire c'est que chaque fois que
vous mettez enfin maintenant vous avez
arrêté mais chaque fois vous mettiez un
morceau d'Édith Piaf assez intéressant
parce que j'ai une malédiction
malédiction de Piaf mais je suis pas le
seul en plus oui Harold qui est le
meneur de jeu de repas vous a dit tu
sais c'est vrai il y a beaucoup de gens
qui nous ont appelé chaque fois qu'ils
mettent Piaf dans leur voiture c'est pas
tellement ça c'est que autour de pierref
il y a une il y a une il y a une
malédiction au début j'ai pris en
rigolant j'ai un jour je suis parti en
bagnole et puis je cassette de Piaf
j'écoute et puis je me choque trois
radars je trouve pas le gars là enfin
que des merdes je fais pas de relation
de cause à effet et puis je sais que
Sardou à l'époque et on rentre de gala
un soir j'écoute Piaf j'enlève la
cassette je mets la radio je retombe sur
pied à la radio je me prends un shoot un
feu rouge j'explose je prends un carton
bon je sors de l'hôpital une semaine
après je dis puis dans ma tête je me dis
je suis pas trop superficieux mais je me
dis bon ça fait deux fois que j'ai des
emmerdements
et je jette la cassette j'avoue par la
fenêtre puis je m'arrête à une
station-servie je me dis quand même je
suis trop con je reprends la cassette et
je et je fais 100 mètres et j'ai les
deux pneus qui explosent depuis tu vois
j'ai et j'ai parlé de ça un jour à la
radio et bizarrement il y a plein de
gens qui ont appelé pour me dire il y a
une vraie malédiction j'en ai parlé à
Jacques Martin qui me disait à l'Empire
dans la salle il y a une truc une loge
dès que quelqu'un veut imiter Piaf il y
avait un projet qui tombe et la fille se
casser la jambe j'en ai parlé à briali
aussi qui m'a dit que chaque fois qu'il
a voulu montrer la robe de Piaf à
quelqu'un à ce moment-là on lui
annonçait un décès c'est quelque chose
qui a
elle a eu un destin quand même qui qui a
attiré un petit peu tout ça
il y a eu et puis quand ils ont voulu
tourner le film de de Leuch le film n'a
pas marché de verre s'est suicidé je
veux dire j'ai eu j'ai eu des choses
encore plus il y a eu des choses
terrorisé j'ai eu des choses encore plus
grave si tu veux qu'ils m'ont touché
c'est-à-dire que j'ai vécu avec cette
malédiction en permanence et puis le
jour mon fils c'est dur en moto j'ai pas
plus aller à la mort de leur connaître
j'ai dit aux flic qui était là il
m'appelle au téléphone qui me dit
reconnaître le corps j'y attendais je
peux je peux pas bouger rien et j'ai dit
débat décrivé décrivez-moi puisqu'on
était pas sûr que ce soit lui et le mec
il me dit bah il a un blouson de
cuillère avec un aigle sur le dos et
j'ai vu la chanson et il m'a récité la
chanson quoi et depuis je suis mais je
suis pas le seul hein j'avais parlé à
des dépôts aussi il se trouvait quand
elle faisait un repas avec plein de
monde dans l'année il y avait un mec qui
disparaissait alors je sais pas d'où ça
vient c'est peut-être que ce personnage
aussi de Piaf cette voix qui est pas
plus exceptionnelle qu'une autre il y
avait quelque chose de de bizarre qui
passait elle était toujours habillée en
noir alors c'est peut-être une super
session bizarre mais maintenant je fais
gaffe peut-être que peut-être que les
didiers étaient en train d'écouter Piaf
Mercedes est-ce que bizarre c'est que
vous croyez à ces petites choses de
superstition et que vous croyez pas en
Dieu parce que en général quand même
ouais c'est ça ouais non non je crois
pas je crois l'homme c'est à dire je
suis je suis un humaniste c'est-à-dire
que je crois que toi c'est moi c'est lui
c'est moi lui c'est moi désolé
je crois que je crois qu'on a le même
moteur monté sur des carrosseries
différentes et c'est pour ça que je suis
humaniste il y a que j'aime les gens et
que je base de la population de vie sur
l'amour vous avez jamais été tenté de
croire même dans les moments les plus
difficiles de votre vie vous avez jamais
dit et des mois ou ben non parce qu'ils
m'ont aidé avant et puis non je veux
dire le côté je vais croire en Dieu
parce que je vais mourir attention il va
falloir que j'aille là-haut oui ça fait
un peu l'assurance contre ça je pense
qu'il y a quelque chose mais c'est la
religion dieu est amour et puis au nom
de ça il y a une religion contre une
autre tu as eu le nombre de morts que ça
fait quel pape a une belle robe c'est
joli
on va passer donc je disais on vous
présentant quand vous avez connu
imitateur animateur maintenant vous êtes
réalisateur vous êtes acteur dans un
film qui s'appelle thème qui sort le 26
avril
d'une façon un peu violente dans une
cave il croit que c'est ça l'amour
mais c'est vrai que c'est vrai que je
crois je dis pas qu'il faut pas te
cacher du tout mais la France est le
pays qui utilise pratiquement le plus de
tranquillisant la principale cause de
suicide chez les dehors chez les jeunes
c'est l'amour c'est le suicide donc il y
a un manque d'amour quand tu rentres
dans un asile la première chose que font
les pensionnaires c'est venir te
caresser et donc il y a un manque
quelque part et c'est surtout un film
sur les a priorités
tu me donnes combien de temps
je sais pas Marie ma chérie mais
qu'est-ce qu'il y a Marie n'est pas
prononcé un seul mot depuis le drame
c'est mal ce que tu as fait très mal la
petite Marie Marie
pour elle est un an
ge on va t'aimer vraiment
je vous laisse six mois pile pour faire
un miracle
depuis des mots le plus dangereux c'est
vous faites lui confiance pendant de
quoi au nom de l'amour absolu
[Musique]
Marie ton père arrive demain il est
important de
je peux rien faire
[Musique]
et que j'ouvre mes veines si je peux
dans les pièges couler la vie en donnant
la mienne
ça s'appelle thème c'est un film de
Patrick Sébastien réalisé écrire réalisé
par Patrick Sébastien et dans lequel il
joue et la chanson c'est ça
[Musique]
a Fiori en soi et il est parti et que sa
fiancé de l'époque ils ont travaillé sur
le sur la chanson il m'a rendu ça nous
ayez pas peur qu'on vous qu'on vous
prenne pour un gourou à force de chanter
la loi l'amour absolu je veux pas faire
de secte moi je crois ça je veux
convaincre un par un maximum de gens
mais je suis pas le seul on est plein
Jésus qui était comme ça ouais mais
comme je me dis comme je me dis enfin
comme je fais dire pas le maire qui me
parle à moi vous prenez pour le Christ
mais vous êtes trop gras c'est de la
lucidité non mais je pense que good par
goût on arrivera à faire comprendre même
si c'est pas la mode aujourd'hui que
l'amour absolu c'est à dire regarder les
gens différemment les respecter quel que
soit leur taille leur poids leur couleur
leur origine sociale c'est quoi qu'il
fasse c'est l'avenir je vois je vois pas
par quoi d'autre on ne peut passer moi
je veux dire un truc je veux pas entamer
une une conversion à l'écran mais enfin
vous êtes beaucoup plus chrétien que ce
que vous croyez Patrick Sébastien mais
sans sans la croix sans la caste mais il
y a plein de symboles ça s'appelle
Marie-Ève mais petit c'est pas innocence
de Joseph alors bon la critique
évidemment ça va être compliqué parce
que c'est vrai que Paris c'est sûr que
oui d'abord j'ai eu du mal à monter le
film parce que vous connaissez personne
dans le métier vous n'êtes pas le fils
de quelqu'un vous n'êtes pas le cas
c'est pas la carte quelqu'un vous n'êtes
pas la carte oui c'est pas une copie et
puis je suis clown à la télé puis c'est
pas une comédie c'est à tout le monde
s'est dit et ça aurait été plus facile
pour vous d'ailleurs de monter une
comédie mais souvent on attendait que ça
soit une comédie c'est ce qu'il y avait
ce que j'avais dans le ventre je crois
que le plus beau la plus belle critique
que j'ai une fois qu'ils arrivent
derrière je l'ai eu d'un mec de
fréquence Nord je crois ou qu'il y a vu
le film et qui fait la Lille et qui m'a
dit je suis rentré dans le cinéma à
reculant parce que je voulais pas y
aller je suis sorti arculant parce que
je voulais pas en sortir et ça ça m'a ça
m'a vraiment touché mais vous dites vous
partez un peu battu au niveau de la
critique parce que peu importe la
qualité de mon premier film les
professionnels ne vont pas aimer et même
s'ils aiment ils le diront pas parce que
c'est Sébastien ah bah c'est un peu vrai
ouais
j'ai déjà eu j'ai déjà eu un peu
c'est lucide on le sait je veux dire les
mecs de télé tu imagines ça fait des
années qui disent de moi que je suis
vulgaire ils vont pas d'un seul coup euh
il y a le contraire moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est comme toujours comme
dans tout ce que j'ai fait à la télé au
music-hall c'est les gens c'est c'est
les vrais normaux c'est cela c'est cela
qui m'intéresse alors la production
exécutive a été faite par votre parent
très épouse on s'est démerder le
Catherine était fait par ma mère je veux
dire on s'est épousé Nathalie en fait au
départ vous avez fait ce mariage comme
ça pour faire une fête et puis vous vous
êtes aperçu finalement que ça vous
donnait un sacré équilibre et vous dites
à 45 ans c'est la première fois que je
m'appuie sur une femme ouais parce que
jusqu'à présent je ouais ouais c'est
quelqu'un qui me porte et plus fragile
et plus fragile que moi même porte un
porte vraiment c'est à dire que je vécu
je sais pas c'est un avec elle on s'est
marié on s'est marié pour faire la fête
pour se faire plaisir on s'est marié sur
le stade de Brive de 10000 personnes
pour que ce soit beau c'est avec des
valses de Vienne moi je trouve aussi
on va se faire un souvenir génial
et quand on s'est retrouvé le soir on
s'est aperçu que ça allait changer
quelque chose alors que j'en suis au 4e
donc je suis habillé dites-moi c'est un
peu votre bébé à tous les deux ce film
alors ouais on a la malchance de ne pas
pouvoir en avoir et c'est rédhibitoire
c'est notre bébé ouais c'est notre petit
donc on y met toute la tendresse et même
dans la même dans la forme dans dans le
sujet qu'on a traité
c'est ça fait partie des différences
aussi de ne pas pouvoir avoir d'enfant
est-ce que là vous avez un autre en
préparation j'en ai plein j'ai plein
mais ça va dépendre si tu la marche un
petit peu parce que moi
sur le
je trouve que le bois de Boulogne que tu
connais aussi
on est juste à côté je trouve que dans
le non je trouve que le bois est un
endroit passionnant non non sérieux
c'est vachement bien il se passe des
trucs extraordinaires il y a de la
violence il y a de l'amour il y a il y a
de il y a de la tendresse il y a des
trucs cachés il y a des ministres qui
viennent il y a moi j'habite à côté mais
et c'est vrai qu'il y a une et c'est
parti en fait le Sénart je vais écrire
par une histoire vraie je connais un
travesti qui a une allure de femme et
qui est papa d'une petite fille
c'est quelque chose de riche et si je te
raconte l'histoire la vraie histoire
c'est même au-delà de scénario ils vont
me dire c'est pas possible vous savez
encore imiter ah ouais ça m'arrive
faites-moi un truc là parce que ça
commence à nous manquer là depuis le
temps je sais pas trop difficile Giscard
d'Estaing non c'est pour mon truc ça
jusqu'à lui je l'entends je raconte des
histoires à la con non je faisais
Bourvil aussi et puis ce que je faisais
c'est que j'arrivais à prendre la tête
des gens quand je faisais je préfère
Dassin et Dassin c'était ma tête c'était
rien du tout je séchais ma lèvre
supérieure
[Applaudissements]
on va faire comme votre film ça risque
d'être un peu difficile avec les
critiques pas avec le public avec les
critiques non pour le moment ça va
encore bon voilà ça va très bien alors
moi je vais vous faire une interview et
vous allez me répondre en question que
je vais vous poser en imitant des gens
je déteste ça vous détestez quoi à faire
des imitations comme ça vous le propos
mais vas-y tout le temps bon il pouvait
le faire pendant 3 heures sans le dire
pas une limitation
bon alors ça s'appelle l'interview
serpent pour ne bouge pas pendant le
jingle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai bougé oui ah bah oui je suis con
faut tout faire
est-ce qu'on peut rappeler Mohamed El
Fayet si vous voulez parce que j'ai dit
alors est-ce que vous êtes prêts
c'est comme normalement ça s'appelle
l'interview de Drucker mais
je l'appelle l'interview serpent quoi
pareil Patrick Sébastien est-ce que vous
a déjà dit que vous aviez une vraie
belle gueule
on peut pas me dire des choses pareilles
oui avec la tête que j'ai depuis les
oreilles décalés
j'ai vraiment pas quand je me regarde
dans la glace c'est pas bien
[Applaudissements]
Patrick
avec une bouche comme ça vous devez
hyper bien embrasser non tibéry
alors juste des idées
[Applaudissements]
votre charisme vous le sortez d'où
je vais te dire
un truc que j'ai pas bien donc je viens
je peux pas te dire et puis tes
questions à la con je commence à en
avoir plus
comment comment vous faites pour être
aussi facile à vivre tous les jours ben
je sais pas du tout c'est parce que
c'est sûrement dans ma nature profonde
tu vois c'est toi par exemple tu es un
gars qui est
facile à vivre aussi très facile non
plus
toi tu es très gentil avec ta femme tu
me l'as dit de très gentil il a une
conception au de l'adultère qui est
terrible il me dit toujours sucé c'est
pas trompé puis dans le cul ça compte
pas le jour
merci ça va salut je t'appelle après
l'émission pas de problème
vous savez ce que signifie pour les
hommes avoir un nez un peu prémilant
comme ça écoutez
en comparaison un organe sexuel de la
même taille c'est quelque chose de
magnifique c'est quelque chose qui m'a
porté c'est aussi emmerder je sais plus
après
pour finir je vais te faire Gainsbourg
c'est pas que
c'est pas mon truc j'aime pas l'odeur
c'est comme les tripes c'est quand
là tu sais quoi en fait
c'est parce que je suis un vrai excessif
que c'est que si je me mets le nez
dedans c'est pas fini ok
bien remarque c'est c'est à la mode dans
le chemise hein il y a les couloir télé
tu passes tapes dans le dos des mecs tu
as les ponts blanches
et alors voilà attends pourquoi attends
merde
pourquoi aucune femme ne peut vous
résister
c'est pas loin
tout le monde me résume tu t'entraînes à
faire Drucker mais là je suis j'y arrive
non
moi j'aime bien
qui disait Drucker était tellement
gentil quand on lui donnait un coup de
pied dans les couilles il vous demandez
si vous n'êtes pas fait mal au ventre
[Applaudissements]
maintenant la lauréate du 20e prix
remicheneller pleut-il le courant
mesdames messieurs ce qu'il vous
connaissez Kad et Olivier Patrick
Sébastien alors vous êtes comme je viens
de le dire Clotilde le Coureau la
lauréate du 20e prix Romy Schneider pour
en face de Mathias Ledoux et Guillaume
Canet a eu lieu le 20e prix Jean Gabin
pour je règle mon passe sur le pas de
mon père
de Mathias Ledoux et lui c'était pour je
règle mon pas sur le pas de mon père de
Rémi Waterhouse
qui monte en ce moment vous avez une
double actu alors on y va tout de suite
vous avez un film à l'affiche bientôt
qui s'appelle la parenthèse enchantée où
vous incarnez personnage comme ça une
fille au début des années 70 une fille
du MLF et alors à l'inverse vous êtes la
semaine prochaine sur scène dans une
pièce où là vous incarnez une
le film c'est la parenthèse enchantée de
Michel Spinoza avec Vincent Elbaz rush
disait Karine Viard et Géraldine
paillasse ça sort le 26 avril alors la
parenthèse enchantée c'est une
expression qui a été inventée par
Françoise Giroud et François Giroud a
inventé l'expression nouvelle vague et
elle a inventé une autre expression qui
a fait ça non elle a inventé une
deuxième expression qui est la
parenthèse enchantée alors la parenthèse
a chanté c'est l'époque qui va de
l'arrivée de la pilule à l'arrivée du
sida quoi c'est l'époque on va vous en
souvenez
on a eu le bol nous on a notre
génération laquelle des vieux je crois
qu'on a eu le bol de vivre les les vins
les 20 années de l'humaine de toute
l'histoire de l'humanité on pouvait pas
mourir en faisant l'amour avant il y
avait la syphilis puis après il y a une
incidence calé juste un bonheur c'est un
bonheur énorme donc c'est une histoire
qui se passe dans les années 70 il y a
trois filles la coincé la sage la
militante des deux garçons le jouisseur
est complexé donc déjà belle brochette
de personnages alors il couche voilà ces
années 70 quoi il couche il se marie il
se qui se retrouvent c'est la fameuse
décennie de la libération sexuelle alors
ce qu'on découvre dans le film c'est un
petit peu ce qui est sorti d'ailleurs de
cette fameuse époque des années 70 c'est
que le plaisir ne mène pas toujours au
bonheur
et d'ailleurs Michel Houellebecq qui est
mon invité tout à l'heure vous serez là
vous le dira il a fait un bouquin
là-dessus vous avez quelque chose à
ajouter
c'est un très beau film que j'aime
beaucoup
et c'est Clotilde de Kourou qui est venu
s'asseoir à côté de moi
j'ai du pot
sincère drôle et ceux qui n'ont pas vécu
cette époque ça peut leur faire ça peut
permettre de la comprendre un petit peu
mieux et comprendre un peu les parents
comment ils ont été tout ça on va en
parler des parents en attendant on va
voir un extrait du film
vous avez passé avec succès le stade de
la technique de compression
il est temps si vous en êtes d'accord de
passer à l'étape du coït proprement je
suis d'accord et toi la tension se
dirige désormais vers la femme il est
juste qu'une fois l'éjaculation mieux
contrôlée elle puisse donner libre cours
aux manifestations de son désir on ne
doit pas faire des commentaires
[Musique]
placez-vous en position de masturbation
compression le passage d'une position à
l'autre n'est pas très facile à réaliser
faisons-nous recommander quelques
répétitions sans pénétration je suis pas
sûr que ce soit comme ça si l'homme de
sa main gauche doit élever vers lui la
cuisse gauche
lui-même dégage sa jambe gauche et
l'appli de façon
à 45 degrés
un coussin sous-elle pour être plus à
l'aise
[Musique]
et le bras droit
c'est pas du tout comme ça
la parenthèse enchantée
c'est Michel Spinoza avec entre autres
copines de Kourou qui est notre invité
ce soir ça c'est le film alors il y a il
y a une pièce c'est un malade ou ça
c'est c'est pas d'hier donc il y a
malade c'est du 27 avril au 1er juillet
mise en scène de Jérôme Savary c'est à
Chaillot alors c'est une prostituée au
grand cœur c'est ça non ouais ça a été
écrit par bref fort qui était un
chauffeur de taxi qui était le roi de
l'argot
qui a terminé au Canard Enchaîné
Alexandre exactement ça a été les
paroles ont été écrites enfin la musique
a été composée par Marguerite mono qui a
composé qui a composé
la pièce et puis elle est tombée
amoureuse elle est partie ailleurs et la
pièce été créé par
bravo
[Applaudissements]
public c'est de faire des quiz culturels
le samedi soir ça a été créé
bravo et voilà et voilà c'est la
grandeur du service public de faire des
quiz culturels le samedi soir c'est bien
c'est culturel ces missions merde c'est
pour ça moi je la regarde régulièrement
son nom français c'est Fabrice en
américain je sais pas
quel bravo quelle est la capitale de la
Slovaquie
Sacha Guitry mais c'est parce que je
fais des grosses personne ne sait la
capitale
ne bougez pas et vous allez être une
star pendant trois secondes vous allez
voir c'est formidable le lendemain au
bureau ça peut aider toutes les
gonzesses ils vont vous chercher des
cafés
[Musique]
vous êtes intéressante parce que vous
êtes le produit de trois décalages je
sais pas si vous êtes déjà réfléchi à ça
non d'abord premier décalage d'ailleurs
vous allez prendre conscience ce soir de
votre personnalité 1er décalage vos
parents sont des déclassés c'est déjà un
décalage parce que votre mère s'appelait
Dupont ta vie des renards un peu comme
dans le spectacle de Valérie Lemercier
tu sais la Renardière votre père était
d'une grande famille d'industrielle et
vos parents c'était les années 68
justement comme dans le film avait
décidé de vivre autrement en refusant
les valeurs traditionnelles
que les noms ne voulaient rien dire donc
déjà vous vous étiez enfant de Jean puis
au départ d'une façon extrêmement
bourgeoise et qui en fait vivait un peu
Baba non mais complètement elles sont
partis en Afrique voilà ça c'est la
deuxième décalage vous êtes parti en
Afrique vos parents sont partis en
Afrique vous avez passé votre petite
enfance au vous avez été élevé pas du
tout comme les autres petits blancs
parce que vos parents justement cet
esprit Baba aidant ils ont mis à l'école
municipale de Cotonou alors vous mangiez
baigné à la banane sardines grillées et
vous aviez une maison en argile sans eau
les électricité c'est vrai ça en brousse
dans un petit village près de savais et
donc on vivait dans le village qui sont
effectivement des maisons en argile sans
eau sans électricité voilà tout le temps
magnéto Serge
alors vos parents vos parents Clotilde
rejeter les biens matériels et vous
quand même vous avez pas complètement la
même conception des choses vous vous
dites que le bien matériel engendre
quand même une certaine liberté oui
parce qu'à force de voir des huissiers
des barqués à la maison et voir la
maison vider parce que l'argent c'est
pas tellement important et à un moment
donné on prend conscience que finalement
l'argent c'est quand même important
premier décalage donc vos parents
déclassés deuxième décalage d'Afrique 3e
décalage vous rentrez en France et là
c'est le choc après la brousse à votre
mère trouve un poste au lycée technique
de bervilliers votre père il se retrouve
au chômage et vous allez vivre dans
l'appartement de votre grand-mère et là
ça a été un effectivement un traumatisme
traumatisme terrible éducation
bourgeoise
on n'avait pas les petites les robes
qu'il fallait les chaussures qu'il
fallait donc on était toujours mis au
coin avec ma sœur
et puis moi j'ai enlevé régulièrement
mes chaussures j'étais mieux
donc il y avait un gros décalage
très jeune parce que vous aviez
Alexandre Alexandre mon premier fiancé
les papas le papa et la maman d'alexan
était copain avec les propriétaires
d'Alcazar
on a eu une éducation très libre sans
aucun interdit donc moi j'allais dormir
chez mon copain Alexandre qui me faisait
embrasser sa chaussette sale 100 fois
parce que pour lui prouver que je
l'aimais
le faire ça je vais le faire ça
chérie garde-moi mes chaussettes
c'est pas mal
j'en ai fait des choses
sept ans donc on avait le droit de
rentrer Alexandre et beaucoup une jeune
danseuse qui était américaine
il y avait des gros ballons qui étaient
lancés à la fin du spectacle et moi il y
avait qu'une seule chose qui
m'intéressait si c'était ce gros ballon
qu'il fallait que je réussisse à sortir
et il y avait toujours un mec bourré
qui crever le ballon qui savait que la
tête à 16 ans vous abandonnez le lycée
de Neuilly pour vous mettre au théâtre
parce que j'étais vraiment traumatisée
donc on a dû me retirer de l'école
[Musique]
je faisais vraiment j'avais des grosses
langues
au cinéma vous gagnez 150000 balles sur
Elisa vous dites c'est hallucinant parce
que votre sœur et votre mère gagnait à
peu près 7000 balles par mois donc c'est
vrai gagner 150 000 balles sur un film
c'est beaucoup et après vous avez
réalisé finalement au cinéma on
travaille pas tous les jours et que
150000 balles par an c'est pas beaucoup
ça fait pas grand chose
c'est le problème au départ on voit
arriver une grosse somme on se dit
génial je vais tout claquer et
puis très vite
je vous demande de vous arrêter votre
ambition c'est toucher le million là
tout simplement
en 90 dans le petit criminel c'était
nominés pour jeunes espoir au César et
tout de suite j'ai du pot quand même
tout de suite vous avez été remarqué par
Hollywood une partie faire un film avec
Paul masure ski tout de suite
Hollywood
qui s'appelle le cornichon
[Musique]
à l'époque j'ai cru que c'était de la
chance mais j'avais oublié que pickles
ça voulait dire cornichon mais bon c'est
pas grave
ça prend l'anglais tu dis merde tu es
dans le cornichon
une réputation caractérielle
vous
êtes très simple à vivre
donc je me suis chopé une
réputation de caractériel et puis j'ai
eu du mal à effectivement à auditionner
les gens que vous voulez plus travailler
avec moi j'étais à la RAM au chômage
mais je crois que ça fait pas c'est le
métier quoi puis après vous êtes
remarqué par Bertrand Tavernier Bertrand
Tavernier a été le premier fictivement à
me dire tiens je t'avais remarqué dans
le petit criminel j'ai un tout petit
rôle si ça t'intéresse et ça faisait un
an que j'étais au chômage donc tout d'un
coup effectivement je les remercie quoi
et puis après j'ai auditionné pour Jean
Becker et il y a eu Elisa les gens m'ont
remarqué et puis j'ai coincé mon pied
dans la porte et j'ai fait cette fois ci
Fais ça j'ai pas beaucoup dehors
je l'ai pas encore on va vous faire vous
connaissez l'émission il faut pas bouger
pendant le jingle vous savez ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il a bougé
c'est pour casser les règles un peu ça
va aller c'est l'interview croyance sans
avoir en quoi vous croyez
est-ce que vous croyez en Dieu
Z2 déjà est-ce que vous croyez au diable
non
est-ce que vous croyez à la baisse des
impôts par Laurent Fabius
vous croyez pas aux extraterrestres
ça me fait toujours rire est-ce que vous
croyez aux petits signes du destin non
oui
en plus elle est là merci
est-ce que vous croyez la vie éternelle
non est-ce que vous croyez au voyante
est-ce que vous croyez que vous allez
vous marier
mais le mariage
du premier anniversaire de votre premier
enfant
je crois qu'on
ça arrive de dire des conneries
incarnation non
est-ce que vous croyez au fantômes non
aux anges gardiens
va se mettre d'accord pour trouver un
candidat à Paris
concernant les candidatures à la mairie
de Paris il y a quelqu'un qui peut vous
aider
c'est le conseiller de jean-thibéry
c'est Bernard Blaise
Bernard Blade bonsoir
vous connaissez Patrick Sébastien un peu
je regarde la télévision
qui se passe au début des années 70 vous
avez vécu le début des années 70
pas une pièce d'ailleurs c'est une
comédie musicale qui s'appelle Irma la
douce à Chaillot mis en scène par Savary
et où elle chante vous chantez vous
connaissez un air là comme ça de mémoire
c'est difficile à froid
ce qu'on a raconté tout à l'heure oui
sur Edith Piaf l'accident donc je vous
ai raconté je venais de poser Gérard
Daguerre chez lui
[Applaudissements]
je suis venu de le déposer chez lui
c'est vrai il était dans la bagnole avec
moi j'étais au courant de cette histoire
c'est la malédiction Piaf c'est à dire
que lui il écoute des cassettes on en
parle pas parce que non non on arrête on
arrête tu vas nous porter la poêle tu
verras
vous savez limiter de temps en temps
vous êtes secrétaire général de la Ville
de Paris exact vous êtes chef
d'état-major du QG politique de
jean-thibéry à la mairie de Paris vous
êtes commis c'est un petit peu de
ketchup sur le truc
vous êtes commissaire général à l'an
2000 voilà ça c'est votre titre officiel
officiellement commissaire général à
l'an 2000 c'est Bernard qui a remplacé
le pauvre Yves Mourousi quand il a
écouté Édith Piaf alors officieusement
vous êtes la tête pensante du maire
son éminence grise son âme d’année
son Richelieu
son Mazarin
et vous êtes aussi vous avez un autre
surnom qui est assez drôle c'est
Monsieur un dossier par élu parce qu'il
paraît que vous dites toujours on a ce
qu'il faut sur tout le monde
j'ai des fiches il a des pommes
vous êtes en train la mairie de Paris en
1962 il y a 38 ans 38 ans c'est pas
d'hier alors vous êtes le neveu du
grammairien célèbre bled ça c'était
votre oncle le grammairien
vous êtes le fils d'un petit
fonctionnaire d'une vendeuse vous avez
pensé votre enfance à Malakoff oui vous
avez
et vous êtes devenu agent de agent de
bureau oui c'est passionnant vous êtes
marié assez jeune plus rapidement deux
enfants et vous étiez obligés pour
doubler votre salaire d'aller vendre du
fromage sur les marchés à 6h du matin ça
c'est vrai sauf que je ne doublais pas
mon salaire ah bon ça suffisait pas pour
doubler votre salaire à l'époque je
gagnais par mois ce que vous gagnez par
jour c'est-à-dire 500 francs
au début j'ai entendu ça en attendant un
peu mais c'est très bien d'ailleurs et
le marché ça rapportait 200 francs par
mois à peu près c'était pas la joie
d'ailleurs votre femme était obligé
d'être nourrice exact elle avait 5
enfants dans votre petit appartement à
Levallois enfin tout je dis tout ça
parce que Monsieur bled a commencé dur
dans la vie
ça ne me semblait pas très dur à ce
moment-là et vous êtes rentré à la
mairie vous êtes recommandé par votre
grand-mère alors vous avez monté tous
les échelons et alors quand Chirac est
arrivé c'était le début de votre
réussite parce qu'il vous a fait tout de
suite confiance Jacques Chirac quand il
est arrivé en 77 moi j'étais déjà là
depuis 15 ans et il se trouve que le
service où je travaille à ce moment-là
qui était le service du protocole était
un service qui était très proche de lui
et très rapidement on s'est connu on
s'est aimé voilà et ça n'a jamais
confiance de Bernadette aussi oui aussi
la famille
je continue à bien l'aimer
alors vous avez des Jacques Chirac à
verrouiller le système parisien quoi ce
qui veut dire s'appuyer plus sur
l'administration que sur les élus
Jacques Chirac c'est un fonctionnaire le
métier quelque sorte donc quand il est
arrivé là à la ville il a trouvé déjà
une administration qui était solide
préfectoral donc c'est vrai qu'il s'est
assez rapidement appuyé sur ce qui
existait mais c'est aussi appuyé sur les
élus et sur certains élus notamment 95
évidemment c'est la c'est le bonheur
vous embrassez Bernadette ouais c'est
vrai ça
sur dire que le moment était un peu
exceptionnel on est c'est presque
surréaliste il est un peu plus de 20h le
résultat de l'élection présidentielle
est connue Jacques Chirac est seul dans
son bureau avec sa femme et Claude
Chirac il y a personne dans les couloirs
de l'hôtel de ville Claude a fait le
ménage il y a plus un chat plus un
journaliste personne c'est Claude qui
faisait le ménage à la mairie de
l'étang sont difficiles et moi je me
trouve là à ce moment-là c'est vrai
Chirac sort il est Président et Madame
Chirac est avec lui l'eau était avec lui
on est tout seul dans ce grand cette
grande maison
c'est pas spontanément
là et je lui dis j'ai envie de vous
embrasser alors c'est une pulsion qui a
été unique pas unique parce que
peut-être dans la sienne aussi je ne
sais pas c'est la première fois qu'elle
m'a embrassé j'ai embrassé ça peut c'est
nécessairement unique bien et là vous
devenez alors là bon Chirac devient
président de la République vous devenez
confidant de tibéry enfin très proche de
de gentilles Berry vous l'aidez beaucoup
vous l'aidez d'abord quand il y a eu
l'affaire du rapport bidon de Xavier
un truc énorme c'est que la semaine
dernière il y avait éric Raoult à votre
place et à un moment Éric Raoul tu es
devenu jeune tout boniste ça
m'intéressait de savoir quel était
l'idéologie du jeune tout boniste
c'était un peu compliqué il m'a pas trop
bien répondu
et alors vous il y a une tentative de
putsch tout boniste
mais c'est quelque chose on peut être
tout bonus il y a des tentatives de
putsch tout bonus et alors là vous avez
aidé gentil Berry contre la tentative de
putsch tout boniste et vous avez eu
cette phrase qui est dans votre dans
votre manière vous avez dit je veux les
voir à poil mais c'est un peu comme
l'interview qui précède mais c'était pas
exactement la même chose c'est une image
absolument
se trouver un peu démunis par rapport
à tous les avantages qui pouvaient avoir
dans leur vie quotidienne à l'hôtel de
ville je voulais savoir simplement
savoir si leur conviction était plus
forte que les avantages annexes je me
suis aperçu qu'en réalité je m'étais pas
trompé c'était plutôt les avantages
c'est comme ça que ça c'est délité assez
vite alors qu'est-ce qui va se passer là
au RPR là maintenant comment il va être
choisi ce candidat parce que pour le
moment il y a pas de là franchement si
vous pouviez m'éclairer moi ça me
rendrait service vraiment qu'est-ce
qu'on fait pour être dans un monde
meilleur qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce
qu'on fait parce qu'il y a les écarts
qui sont de plus en plus
de plus en plus grand il y a vraiment
des gens qui sont en train de crever la
dalle il y en a d'autres qui s'en
mettent plein les poches donc qu'est-ce
qu'on fait concrètement le RPR le bidule
le bidule
qu'est-ce qu'il fout là quoi sans
déconner qu'il soit dans son bureau en
train de travailler quoi merde
Chirac quoi super ça a pas de rapport
avec la précarité
pas moi parce que concrètement ça ne
change rien ça fait des années qui
disent que ça change et on se retrouve
systématiquement dans la merde et
systématiquement tu prends le métro tu
as des gens qui crèvent la dalle quoi il
y a un truc alors il y en a marre de
nous de nous berner comme ça il y en a
marre elle a un peu raison que le titre
dans le sens où on a l'impression qu'on
prend un temps fou à choisir qui va
représenter et c'est vrai
elle passe c'est de la merde
apparemment les riches étaient de plus
en plus riches et les pauvres de plus en
plus ça c'est une poussette
moi ce qui m'embête un peu c'est tout ce
temps qu'on prend parce que pendant ce
temps là les mecs ils se font chier
quand même tout ce temps comprend pour
lire celui qui va représenter qui a pas
les mêmes idées à 2,3
Patrick si ça tenait qu'à Bernard
lui c'est pas de sa faute il y a trois
autres candidats quoi on se désintéresse
totalement ce qui est ce qui est
terrible bien sûr
moi je trouve qu'il y a un truc quand
même qui est que j'ai observé et est-ce
que est-ce que quelque part on va y
mettre fin un jour les 100 abris les
restos du cœur ça devrait pas exister on
a les moyens en France de filer du blé
pour qu'il y ait plus de 100 abris moi
je crois enfin ma théorie à moi c'est
quand Tony qui a une manipulation c'est
que cette petite couche de gens qui sont
très malheureux on l'entretient
volontairement pour que la couche qui au
dessus ferme sa gueule en disant mais il
y a plus malheureux que nous et c'est
pour ça qu'on nous montre sans arrêt des
gens qui sont sans abri etc alors que si
on veut si on veut si l'État veut
vraiment parce que c'est une urgence si
on veut vraiment tous ces gens là les ça
doit plus exister dans notre société on
a les moyens financiers je me demande je
me demande
je me demande juste
s'il y en a un qui aura les couilles un
jour de dire ça on a les moyens de
l'éradiquer parfaitement et c'est vrai
qu'après on va se retrouver avec une
couche beaucoup plus grande de mecs qui
sont à 5000 balles par mois ils vont se
dire maintenant c'est nous qui sommes en
bas on va gueuler voilà je peux vous
répondre en une phrase là-dessus parce
que le problème on va pas le régler ce
soir on pourrait très bien mais si
j'avais la capacité de le faire je le
ferais bien volontiers
parce que ce que vous dites actuellement
ça tombe pile-poil parce que en ce
moment là toute la journée d'aujourd'hui
et la moitié de la journée demain nous
avons organisé à l'Hôtel de Ville de
Paris les états généraux de la
solidarité c'est moi-même qui est mis ça
au point avec le maire il y a plus de 18
mois et ça fait pendant 18 mois nous
avons travaillé avec les 35 associations
de paris caritatives qui sans exception
que de Paris ça si vous voulez pour plus
tard on peut s'occuper d'autres choses
si vous pensez que j'ai un Président si
j'ai un destinational je veux dire autre
chose mais pour l'instant j'arrête mes
capacités au périphériques c'est déjà
pas si mal ça fait déjà 2 millions
100000 personnes c'est déjà pas le plus
grand chose c'est que vous vous
intéressez à ce sujet là de précarité
etc toujours à des dates anniversaire
des dates de d'élection
souvent
il y a non non pour régler ce problème
là on est en politique on dirait qu'il y
a pas d'acte la parole
ecoutez ce que je vous propose camarade
c'est de suspendre cet Alger ses parents
ont été élevés
on met de côté
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que vous avez fait de dire
dans ce journal que vous voudriez gagner
un million au prochain film il va être
obligé de vous le donner
alors c'est pas grave je continue avec
Monsieur je continue avec Monsieur bled
donc les candidats en présence
Clotilde je vois que vous avez été élevé
par des parents 68 j'ai pas pris la
discipline à la maison
j'étais 68 vos parents
monsieur bled
donc il y a Françoise de panacieu je
parle des candidats à la candidature RPR
pour la mairie de Paris
il y a ce gars il y a Édouard Balladur
et Jean tibéry bien sûr qui est déjà
mère bon alors une bonne ambiance quand
on vous parle de Françoise de palafieux
il paraît que vous faites ce signe de
l'égorgement
vous êtes pas très pote avec panaché je
la connais depuis longtemps voilà 21 ans
alors quand il est question de baladure
vous dites c'est une vous dites en
parlant de Jack Lang à l'époque était
candidat vous dites oui toute façon
Jacques Lang quand il était candidat il
a fait autant d'interventions de
Balladur quand il était conseillé c'est
à dire aucune donc déjà vous êtes pas
pour Balladur vous êtes pas monsieur
pardon vous interrompre encore mais
quand à l'intérieur d'une même famille
poétique comme ça vous balancez comme ça
comment voulez-vous
je savais que je suis un ami du
président mais je parle je parle de la
vie parce que j'aime l'homme point je ne
fais pas de politique j'aime l'homme
voilà point et je ne m'intéresse pas
mais quand je vois à sa famille moi ce
tirer des coups de fusil avant de se
faire rire c'est pas crédible après
alors dans ce cas là il faut que le chef
de famille intervienne voilà on va y
venir on va y venir
il serait temps que le parrain il s'en
occupe
je viendrai bientôt en voyage officiel
en France ce gars ce gars c'est un peu
ce gars
ce gars c'est un peu mieux
oui vous avez déclaré en parlant de ce
gain sa vision du gaulisme me convient
et lui a répondu en parlant de vous
d'ailleurs Bernard Blade est une vraie
compétence alors est-ce que vous seriez
pas en train de lâcher tibéry pour ce
gain c'est pas possible je ne sais pas
lâcher quelqu'un que je soutiens ce qui
dit il m'est jamais arrivé ça fait
partie des valeurs du RP sans déconner
[Applaudissements]
alors si attendez comment ça va se
passer comment vous vous dites si le
candidat RPR la mairie de Paris n'est
pas choisi par un vote des militants à
bulletins secrets il n'aura aucune
légitimité où elle n'aura aucune
légitimité et donc tibéry ira jusqu'au
bout voilà susceptible d'y aller en tout
cas comme vous savez qu'il y aura pas de
vote des militants à bulletin secret
jusqu'au bout je ne sais pas alors
maintenant
pas une importante d'ailleurs mes chers
Clotilde c'est pourquoi
tibéry tient
est-ce que tibéry c'est des choses sur
la gestion de l'hôtel de ville du temps
de Chirac qui peut embêter Chirac pour
sa réélection en 2002 est-ce que c'est
pour ça que tibéry tient tibéry tiens
pour plusieurs raisons et celle-là est
la plus mauvaise des raisons la première
raison c'est que il est depuis 35 ans
élu parisien sa seule vision politique
c'est Paris il s'est toujours battu pour
Paris et il a envie de continuer à se
battre pour Paris bon c'est vous voyez
bien clairement
contre lui quand on vous dit il y a le
peuple qui gronde dans la rue vous dites
on s'en fout on a le double vitrage
vous me lisez beaucoup aussi
j'admire quelque part je parle pas du
personnage et tout c'est avec ce qui
prend dans la gueule comment il tient
debout encore
pourquoi vous tenez Bernard on tient
parce que on est solide et bien dans nos
baskets c'est tout sinon on tient pas
moi je vous dis que tibéry doit savoir
des trucs gênantes pour Chirac parce que
sinon il y a longtemps qu'il serait plus
là alors vous vous dites faux hein et
par exemple quand on vous quand on vous
parle des responsables des des
phosphères ou des emplois fictifs avant
1995 vous vous dites sur une chaîne
concurrente mais néanmoins amis il
faudra faire une recherche en paternité
il faudrait faire une recherche en
paternité c'est-à-dire que c'est une
manière de dire ça nous fait chier on
balance tout mais on balance rien du
tout d'abord faudrait-il savoir ce qu'on
a balancé Bernard
je pourrais dire des choses
c'est retenez-moi où je fais un malheur
quoi il a rien dit attendez il a dit si
on touche un ami de Chirac c'est lui en
parlant de lui un petit mail si on
touche un ami de Chirac le RPR peut
tirer un trait sur les municipales les
législatives et les présidentielles donc
il a un soucable il a intouchable
alors un jour il a dit ça en réalité
c'est votre collègue Elkabbache qui lui
a dit il a dit la répéter derrière lui
je suis intouchable en réalité ce qui
voulait dire à ce moment-là c'est pas
qu'il était intouchable à la manière
indienne mais qu'il était intouchable
uniquement parce qu'un maire quand il
était lui mère il reste le maire
jusqu'au bout il y a rien d'autre que si
tibéry est intouchable vous savez bien
que Chirac aussi est intouchable puisque
avant de partir du Conseil
constitutionnel Roland Dumas lui a la
rendu judiciairement intouchable
c'est une responsabilité qui lui incombe
entre nous vous le connaissez bien vous
le voyez tous les jours pourquoi il
cherche pas pourquoi il cherche pas une
sortie honorable ne pourrez-vous
pourquoi voulez-vous qu'il cherche une
sortie il y a pas de raison il y a
qu'une seule chose même si il y a qu'une
seule chose qui vaut même si on croit on
ne croit pas la démocratie moi je crois
la démocratie le seul moyen de sortir ou
de ne pas sortir c'est de se présenter
devant des électeurs si les électeurs
vous disent tu es bon tu restes il vote
pour lui si il était pas bon on t'aime
pas il veut pas pour lui et il s'en va
c'est la seule règle qui vaut tout le
reste c'est du bidouillage est-ce que
Clotilde de courant est-ce que vous
allez vous vous
intéressez aux élections municipales à
Paris
non
Bernard Blaise vous êtes un homme de
coup donc on va vous faire une interview
de coups on va vous faire une interview
dernier coup on éteint
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dernier coup dur
le dernier coup dur
la candidature de Balladur ah oui
dernier coup de cœur
dernier coup de cœur pour l'interview de
Françoise de panafieux dans Elle ouais
qui dit quoi
de choses et elle en dit et sa famille
en est aussi il y a une chose qui m'a
intéressé c'est que sa soeur dit quand
elle était petite
il y a une grande famille cette famille
cette frères et soeur je crois 7 ou 8 et
elle était l'aînée donc elle était la
reine et nous étions ces esclaves et on
lui apportait le savon les chaussons les
trucs comme ça donc ça m'a ça m'a
vraiment intéressé et un peu peut-être
aussi inquiété
dernier coup de poing un collaborateur
qui
que je considère comme étant un peu un
peu loin de mes préoccupations
politiques dernier coup de folie
le soutien permanent à gentil Berry
ouais
dernier coup de foudre
dernier coup de gueule
alors ça le dernier coup de gueule c'est
permanent
à Napoléon III un peu bled il faut
savoir si c'est Raspoutine Richelieu
bazarin Napoléon III physiquement
franchement c'est plus simple
et vous savez que ce gars est créatif
pas beaucoup mais non mais c'est bien
parce que je trouve que c'est quelqu'un
qui dise qu'elle pense et qui est vrai
dernier coup de rouge
et ben c'est il y a deux heures
j'ai fait la cave de l'hôtel de ville
combien vous êtes bouteille c'est un
censé 15000 bouteilles 15000 bouteilles
mesdames messieurs et j'essaie
que le peuple le plus enfin picolé sans
ça vous intéresse
[Musique]
mon dernier coup de chapeau c'est c'est
celui que j'ai donné à gentil Berry
encore
à sa sortie de l'hôpital
parce que ça correspondait à ce
moment-là à une campagne de presse
extravagante
et je trouve que le courage qui est
manifeste en permanence mérite un vrai
coup de chapeau
dernier coup de poker
c'est celui qu'on joue en ce moment
c'est la partie qu'on joue en ce moment
c'est celui-là
et pour finir dernier coup de rang
avant-hier
très bien on rallume
merci Bernard Blade alors vous allez
regarder le match
mercredi soir
dans le football alors nous accueillons
maintenant
de Calais
faire quelques fautes quand même quoi
mais disons que il y a eu des
comportements cools et d'autres moins
cool mais bon si par exemple c'est mal
comportait
un garçon comme du Garry n'a pas été à
la hauteur de son statut je pense
oui mais bon plutôt que de
plutôt que de s'attarder sur les mauvais
comportements je pense que on retient
les les les mots de remerciement qu'on a
eu des différents joueurs et ça ça reste
marqué quoi les maillots vous avez c'est
le vote là oui j'ai l'offrir à qui à mon
oncle je vais déjà offert
c'est un cadeau que je lui offert des je
lui ai offert déjà contre eux contre
Strasbourg à l'occasion du quart de
finale et le jour de mon anniversaire en
plus de mes 25 ans et c'était quel
moment inoubliable déjà pour moi quoi
alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que le
budget du club de Bordeaux c'est 189
millions et le budget du club de Calais
c'est moins 1 million 7
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal vous avez
battu Lille qui était de la des deux
cannes en D2 Strasbourg en D1 et là vous
avez battu Bordeaux qui est quand même
des plus grandes équipes françaises quoi
quand même oui
c'est dû à quoi la niaque bah la niaque
mais bon je pense qu'on comme je vous
l'ai dit tout à l'heure on se prépare
pour pour ces événements à répétition on
a un coach qui est qui est derrière nous
et qui comment il va votre coach là
lazano ça va un peu mieux il a eu un
petit
dans la nuit de mercredi à jeudi après
le match je pense que c'était un peu dû
aussi à la collation il a pratiquement
rien mangé d'après ce que j'ai pu
entendre et puis bon
c'est suite Bordeaux qui écoutait pierre
non mais ça on a eu des nouvelles
rassurantes et je pense que un peu de
repos lui fera du grand bien
alors il sera sur pied pour le 7 mai au
Stade de France donc j'espère contre
contre Nantes oui mais c'est fou parce
que ils ont pas ils ont failli pas jouer
la Coupe de France c'est vrai les
problèmes de pognon j'ai failli pas la
jouer cette coupe de c'est exact parce
que bon disons que diverses instances
ont voulu nous imposer le le match un
tel jour à une telle heure et puis on
est quand même un club amateur bon
nombre de nos supporters sont les
ouvriers on trouvait pas normal et
logique qui viennent
c'est rosé ça quoi
et doivent poser une journée de congés
pour pour venir à ce match quoi qui qui
a des joueurs Christophe est-ce qu'il y
a des joueurs du club de Calais qui ont
été obligés d'aller travailler jeudi
matin dernier
jeudi matin non parce que c'était une
journée quand même c'était une journée
off pour certains certains d'entre nous
moi personnellement je passe mon brevet
d'état pour pour devenir éducateur
sportif 1er degré je me suis rendu à
Liévin ou là j'ai rencontré mes
collègues de formation et où j'ai passé
une journée avec les jeunes et je me
suis vraiment éclaté quoi vous en plus
bon vous êtes vraiment amateur vous êtes
en poids jeune vous bossez au centre
communal d'action sociale c'est vraiment
vous aider les jeunes à faire des CV ou
à trouver des CDD c'est c'est ma
vocation j'ai la vocation du social
j'accueille comme vous l'avez dit des
jeunes qui sont demandeurs d'emploi je
les aide à à les insérer ou les ou les
réinsérer dans le milieu professionnel
et puis bon bah de les aider au mieux à
travers leur parcours leur motivation et
leurs compétences quoi vous allez vous
faire une copine là
mode les actrices avec les footballeurs
faites gaffe quand même
[Musique]
c'est la première fois depuis la
création de la Coupe de France en 1918
que ça arrive quoi c'est c'est énorme
c'est beau pigeons
un petit peu ce genre de compétition de
couple et quand tu commences à avoir
l'embellie comme ça il y a une dynamique
de la victoire qui fait que tu es
intouchable quoi tu as des tripes
énormes je pensais un petit peu au
Danemark en Coupe d'Europe il y a
quelques années c'est l'équipe que tu
attends point qui doit même pas être là
c'est ça c'est le Danemark je crois
ouais
ils ont pas eu la pression des médias
c'est pas de pression et puis et puis ça
devient une aventure c'est ce qu'il y a
de fabuleux dans le sport c'est
l'aventure humaine moi je fais jusqu'à
la finale d'une Coupe d'Europe qu'on a
gagné l'aventure humaine au bout d'un
moment tu es intouchable quoi et là vous
avez c'est énorme ça c'est les plus
belles plus beaux moments qu'est-ce que
vous voulez qu'on vous dise c'est génial
on a tous vibré avec vous
des
[Applaudissements]
idoles nationales moi je suis ravi
d'être là ça va mieux bon alors vanessa
Demouy enfin à nous
avant de parler avec Vanessa Demouy
j'ai fait un goûter un disque j'adore
plus que tout
[Musique]
j'adore cette
moi
[Musique]
c'est un plaisir que je me fais à moi
parce que j'adore ce disque on n'était
pas nombreux à l'adorer mais ça c'est
sorti c'est sorti en quelle année
vanessaie 50000 exemplaires non voilà
c'est moi j'ai fait partie des gens qui
l'ont aimé ce disque ça vous plaît
c'est joli non
viens dans mon rêve de fille j'adore
cette chanson me fait très plaisir en la
mettant c'est enregistré
de rentrer à la maison
[Applaudissements]
donc oui c'était enregistré à Bero en
plus
la plupart de leur de leur disque vous
êtes rare en télé vous avez dit j'avais
besoin de faire un break de changer
d'image
j'avais pas vraiment besoin de changer
d'image c'est j'avais besoin que les
gens
se change l'image qu'ils avaient de moi
moi j'ai pas vraiment changé j'évolué en
tout cas j'espère sept ans mais
non elle est toujours à 46 d'ailleurs
mais vous mesurez vous mesurez parce que
vous
laisse pas embêter
ma copine
vous dites 70 dans les interviews mais
moi je sais que c'est 69
est-ce que vous avez toujours les mêmes
mensurations
vous vous aimez pas tellement ça c'est
un truc c'est un truc
vous dites par exemple je voudrais être
plus grandes d'avoir la peau très mal
les cheveux noirs frisés des grands yeux
enfin je voudrais être métisse ouais je
dis ça quand j'ai très très jeune
pas trop moches parce que tout
simplement on leur dit homme était pas
mal et que c'est comme ça doit être
quand même plus facile on le dit jamais
aux filles qui sont pas très gâtés par
la nature mais a priori elles sont aussi
complexées que les autres poitrine c'est
pas possible c'est pas que j'aimais pas
ma poitrine c'est que tout le monde m'en
parlait donc au bout d'un moment ça
gonfle ça gonfle
bien alors vous venez de terminer
justement parce que bon on a connu tous
Vanessa dans des séries télévisées vous
venez enfin mettez vendu dans 35 pays je
veux dire c'était pas non plus on est
terminé à long métrage il s'appelle le
marquis qui est réalisé par Gilles
Paquet Brenner et qui est écrit par
Virginie Despentes et à qui avec vous
alors dans ce film il y a plein de monde
il y a Patrick Bruel c'est Tony Bugsy
Maïwenn Marion Cotillard
À quoi tu joues juste là pourquoi je
joue
mais c'est pas mon sac où est mon sac
sushi
où est mon sac sushi
vanessa Demouy dans le marquis
ah ouais
c'est plus la mannequin là
vous avez même été un moment vous avez
pensé à faire Lara Croft la version
cinéma de Lara Croft finalement ils ont
pris Angelina Jolie
mais il voulait une Américaine dès le
départ
la suite de 9 semaines et demi
on m'a proposé le film on m'a donné un
scénar qui était très très bien mon
personnage était très très bien dans le
dans le script que j'ai eu c'est un
personnage jeune il y avait absolument
pas de scène dénudés il y avait rien du
tout qui se passait avec Mickey Rourke
on a fait les essais tout se passait
très très bien on faisait le stylisme on
préparait le personnage puis d'un seul
coup le film se faisait en anglais quand
même donc je leur ai dit mais ce serait
bien que j'ai le script en anglais
si mais dans l'intimité
est-ce que vous embrasseriez des
chaussettes
un truc comme ça est-ce que par amour
vous embrasseriez des chaussettes 100
fois 100 fois
par preuve d'amour pourquoi pas
vous vouliez travailler aux États-Unis
en fait parce que vous êtes là-bas on
vous juge sur votre volonté de
travailler pas sur votre image et moi
dites-vous en parlant de vous j'ai
l'impression qu'on les gens parlent de
moi ou j'entends parler de moi ou
quelqu'un vient me répéter un truc il a
entendu qui parle de quelqu'un d'autre
donc au bout d'un moment c'est chiant
d'être toujours obligé de se justifier
de moi je fais pas des auditions faut
que je rencontre des gens et j'ai trois
rendez-vous pour déjà leur faire
admettre que je suis pas la bimbo et que
je vais pas arriver en maillot de bain
spécialement sur mes casting
aux États-Unis
dans le cornichon
dans le cornichon quand même
Vanessa elle a tellement envie de jouer
on apprend tellement pour une bimbo
comme elle dit que des fois elle arrive
pour montrer qu'elle peut jouer des
rôles de mer elle arrivait avec son
petit frère dans les casting pour faire
croire qu'elle était maman c'est vrai
parce que moi il y a un truc qui est
très chiant il y a toujours quelque
chose je donne mon nom c'est alors je
suis trop vieille je suis trop jeune je
suis pas le personnage je suis trop sexy
je suis à croire que je suis pas une
gonzesse quoi je n'existe pas
[Musique]
mais si vous êtes une gonzesse vachement
jolie mais moi je demande que ça les
transformations
un peu les trucs mais c'est vrai qu'on
pourra aller vachement plus loin et
j'adorais le faire d'ailleurs Vanessa le
dit quand on a fait de la télé on est
impériat quoi on est on est marqué c'est
vrai mais c'est difficile aussi pour une
débutante
mais moi on m'a carrément dit tu serais
inconnu ce serait ce serait moins dur
les réalisateurs français ils ont gardé
de vous l'image d'une héroïne de sitcom
hyper maquillée
un peu comme ça quoi
[Musique]
mais tu es carrément aussi bon que par
Dieu
bonjour Olivier pour le rôle de Rafale
Florent ok vendu bonjour
en fait pour elle ça ne sera pas
victoire ça sera Linda mais ce sera
quand même très bien
[Musique]
les secrets les plaisirs les yeux fermés
le coeur les masser il serait possible
pour arrêter le temps un succès
planétaire
[Musique]
la série est exportée dans plus de 30
pays avec des versions parfois exotiques
c'était en coréen
marqué si vous êtes tellement pesé qu'à
un moment vous avez voulu arrêter et
vous dites je peux pas me passer de ce
métier mes amours vous avez même voulu
arrêter tellement c'était pesant d'avoir
fait ça enfin vous avez vraiment envie
en même temps malgré ça vous continuez
parce que vous avez envie de faire ça
depuis toujours quand vous étiez petit
dans la salle de bain vous jouiez la
remise des César toute seule
il y a un seul problème
avec Stéphane heureuse Stéphane
heureuse Stéphane
vous avez quelque chose de commun avec
Clotilde Courau
c'est que vous avez ce même sentiment
c'est-à-dire que Clotilde a vécu une
histoire d'amour très forte avec
quelqu'un mais on s'est rencontré un
dîner un dîner entre vous hein
et donc Clotilde a vécu une histoire
d'amour très forte avec quelqu'un et
quand elle s'est rendu compte que ils
étaient en train de se détruire
mutuellement
ils sont séparés vous de vous dites
quand on aime et qu'on est aimé s'il est
plus possible de vivre ensemble il vaut
mieux se dire adieu plutôt que se
détruire mutuellement
mais c'est vrai mais grave
[Musique]
ah je suis tendre vous savez ça je suis
très sentimental je suis ravie que vous
soyez aperçu l'autre fois quand on était
au cinéma à côté vous avez pas le temps
de vous apercevoir parce que le film il
dure 1h30 mais je suis tendre c'est vrai
non alors c'est vrai vous êtes comme ça
vous aussi plutôt que vous vous avez
vécu une histoire d'amour c'était au
bout de l'histoire et puis un moment
vous êtes dit non elle est en train de
se détruire vous avez arrêté là
c'est vrai ça
même pas pour venir je prends pas
l'ascenseur ici moi
22h
c'est dommage que vous soyez pas enduit
au FOB c'est ce que c'est en Diop
en duophone
c'est les gens qui ont peur de ça
c'est dommage que vous soyez pas rendu
au feu vous voyez c'est quoi c'est les
gens qui ont peur de s'habiller bien sûr
un peu de promo maintenant
ah oui il va falloir apprendre Vanessa
excusez-moi
maintenant on va regarder ce que font en
cas de Olivier sur ce que vous faites
sur Comédie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est à toi de lancer le dé pour ce
premier kaamelote c'est parti le rouge
de mars tu marques 10 chevaux et tu
avances en case morvenez
Olivier je plonge la tête la première et
je mange une perruque très bien oui
c'est pas mal tu fais coup double et tu
lances le javelot Alexandra
poulinen et queue de cheval
à question anatomique quel est le muscle
Dany Brillant
c'est pas évident tu passes par la case
départ et tu prends 10000 Olivier à te
parler quels sont à franges les noms
dire qu'elles sont à franges et Gobelet
d'agneau oh bien joué tu es pauvre
Nicoletta et tu files en casse but de 15
secondes de ramoutcho
ok Alexandre
guitare à moustache en 3C tu peux pas tu
as un mini vélo en opposition
tu descends en case claques beignets
qu'est-ce que tu décides
j'insulte l'homme au pied bout et je
mange du foin au laser club
il est ni rond ni carré ni pointu
[Applaudissements]
qui c'est les plus forts évidemment
c'est les Verts on a un bon public et le
meilleur supporteurs supplémentaires
moi je veux dire cure-dent cure-dent et
cure-dent et
cure-dents cure-dent
[Musique]
j'adore le Jean-Michel à peu près
Jean-Michel à peu près Jean-Michel
c'était Jean-Michel
alors maintenant on va baisser la
lumière vous bougez pas pendant le
jingle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on va faire avec Kad et Olivier qui a
quelque chose bah vous ça vous
surprendra pas parce que souvent j'ai vu
des choses de ce type dans le Grand
Cabaret émission un succès que vous
présentez sur France 2 Patrick Sébastien
alors on va faire une interview
télépathie
donc je vais vous poser des questions
par télépathie et vous allez répondre et
je crois que ça n'a jamais été fait à la
télévision
dans ce qu'on est tellement maintenant
alors Clotilde si c'est pour nous
déconcentrer ça va pas le faire
un petit peu avec Olivier ça marche
aussi bien que les deux de toute façon
interview télépathie première question
répondez 31 cm
au repos
on va faire maintenant
attendez là je me déconcentre s'il vous
plaît c'est compliqué deuxième question
tu peux répéter la fin de la question
non non je trouve pas que Sébastien soit
ringard
je suis pas d'accord
et
[Rires]
que deux barrettes
dernière question
naire on accueille maintenant
l'entraîneur de l'équipe de France de
rugby
Bernard Laporte
ça va
salut Bernard vous connaissez Sébastien
est-ce que c'était un bon je vais
croiser un bon patron de club oui c'est
c'était un bon patron il a fait de
belles choses la preuve il a eu beaucoup
de résultats avec comment il a été viré
Sébastien
tu viens après l'émission dans non non
je vous demande de vous arrêter on va
ce soir
vous savez comment il a été comment il a
été viré de virer non
j'ai pris du recul simplement
Patrick si tu restes président de Brive
on va te mettre des mauvais arbitres on
va te pénaliser donc il est parti
c'est impossible
c'est impossible et la créatine parce
que lui il dit que ils prennent de la
créatine dans le rugby je quitte la
créatine existait dans le rugby en
général et qu'il était pas exclus vous
avez dit ils font pas tout ça avec de
l'eau minérale
je vous l'avais dit ici
donc
moi qui connaît très très bien le rugby
on se connaît depuis pas mal de temps
Bernard Laporte pour moi c'est
pratiquement la plus belle chose qui
soit arrivée au rugby français en
général depuis quelques années c'est un
excellent entraîneur et avec lui s'il a
les mains libres
je crois qu'on sincèrement qu'on peut
être champion du monde
quel bilan vous faites du tournoi des 6
nations alors un bilan mitigé je crois
qu'on a beaucoup de regrets parce que
après avoir gagné largement un Cardiff
ensuite on a eu beaucoup de blessés on
n'a jamais pu aligner j'ai envie de dire
notre équipe majeure donc on a eu des
résultats dans decides donc beaucoup de
regrets mais beaucoup de force et une
certaine latitude des joueurs oui je
crois qu'il y a bon c'est le sujet
actuellement qu'on les joueurs français
jouent trop donc
votre en fait vous voudriez qui joue
moins d'une certaine façon tout à fait
je crois qu'un joueur de mystère Sud
joue 25 matchs par saison un joueur en
France joue 40 donc en plus sur le
mobilise pendant 11 mois ce qui est très
difficile vous avez quand même une
réputation de de tueur un peu de mecs
durs avec les équipes non non il vous
appelle le Kaiser en général les mecs
qu'on appelle le Kaiser c'est pas des
mecs sympas le père de kouron la plupart
le Kaiser mais je sais pas moi j'aime
pas parler de moi et puis celui qui a
dit un jour que j'étais un Kaiser mais
il a certainement des raisons de le dire
non je crois pas que je sois je suis
rigoureux parce que bon j'ai des
convictions et je sais où je veux aller
mais je crois que c'est tout entraîneur
français et comme ça si en train de
Calais il a pas beaucoup de commission
non c'est imperfectionniste mais il est
très chaleureux bah lui aussi il est
chaleureux lui il alterne la porte il
alterne la carotte et le bâton c'est à
dire il est très très chaleureux et des
fois il critique ses joueurs il peut
être très sec comme ça mais il faut si
on veut avancer je crois qu'il faut
effectivement
et puis bon il faut bien faire la part
des choses quoi il y a le terrain et
puis il y a le reste je crois que dans
le rugby il y a une certaine
convivialité qu'il faut pas perdre après
quand on est sur le terrain il faut être
sérieux il faut gagner il faut
s'entraîner avec beaucoup de rigueur
alors vous vous êtes donc entraîneur de
l'équipe de France de rugby vous avez
jamais été international c'est bizarre
ça quand même vous êtes le plus jeune
entraîneur qu'on n'est jamais connu vous
avez jamais été international de rugby
jamais est-ce que ça vous ça vous enlève
pas de l'autorité par rapport aux
joueurs que vous dirigez non je crois
pas que tout à l'heure soit reconnu par
le fait qu'il ait été ou pas
international non ça n'existe plus
pourquoi vous avez pas été international
vous vous en avez envie quand même ah
oui j'ai la même vie mais il y avait
meilleur que moi donc comme on dit je
faisais souvent vous étiez pas assez
costaud
de gens que vous envoyez au combat
contre le monde entier d'une certaine
façon parce que c'est différent
avec beaucoup d'internationaux donc moi
je suis même si j'avais pas le niveau
présentation nationale j'avais le droit
de jouer avec eux si vous êtes venu
comment alors parce que au début bon
vous étiez votre famille d'origine assez
modeste votre père travaille sur les
lignes électriques d'EDF et votre mère
elle se lever à 4h pour distribuer les
les journaux après faisait des ménages
non moi j'ai beaucoup de respect pour ça
oui moi aussi
et ensuite il y a quelqu'un qui vous a
marqué qui c'est lui qui nous a donné
envie c'est Alain Pagès c'est lui qui
vous a donné envie de faire ce métier
c'était mon professeur des questions
physiques qui était au lycée Rascol Albi
et c'est vrai que de l'avoir côtoyé ça
m'a impulsé j'aime bien ça m'a donné
beaucoup d'envies et déjà c'était ma
passion je crois que à son contact et
bien il s'est passé quelque chose j'aime
bien d'électrique c'est que j'ai voulu
un petit peu le copier et il avait de
l'énergie beaucoup d'énergie et quand il
me parlait il avait un charisme énorme
ça montrait ce que c'était quelqu'un qui
avait du charisme quelqu'un qui se
dévouait beaucoup il arrivait vous dites
à l'extérieur 5 pleine de ballons
quelqu'un qui le faisait par cœur par
passion et je crois que ça ça s'oublie
pas alors effectivement vous avez fait
Gaillac Bègles Bordeaux et en 95 c'est
arrivé au stade de France
c'est Max voisini qui vous a qui vous a
demandé de venir vous êtes monté un
petit peu à contre-cœur parce que
quitter le Sud-Ouest pour une équipe
parisienne du groupe B c'était pas
évident qu'est-ce qui vous a séduit
comment il est arrivé à vous convaincre
de venir vous installer ici déjà c'est
vrai que j'avais pas du tout envie de
venir à Paris de plus le club était le
Stade Français c'est SG était un groupe
un groupe B ce qui correspond à la
troisième division
et je suis venu une fois puis max et
quelqu'un de très attachant je crois que
moi j'avais d'abord peur de Paris parce
que c'est vrai que petit provincial qui
monte à Paris on se dit puis bon son
contact je crois que il m'a fait même
trois jours la vie parisienne et vous
amener au Palace c'est vrai
à fréquenter les médias vous habiller je
crois qu'après il m'a beaucoup apporté
mais moi c'est un mec je crois qu'il y a
eu beaucoup de feeling entre nous c'est
réussi
alors il a été le secrétaire particulier
Dalida max voisini et quand il parle de
vous il vous compare à Dalida vous savez
ça
lundi mais surtout qu'est-ce que vous
allez de comparable avec David
il me disait qu'après les après c'est
ces émissions et bien souvent impliquer
des coups de colère il me dit et tu
ressens ma Dalida pendant une demi-heure
après match faut pas te parler c'est ça
je sais pas j'ai pas eu l'occasion de
coller David je sais pas j'essaie de
vous imaginer en Dalida là j'ai du mal
bien alors tous les cas ça a marché
puisque vous avez le bouclier de bonus
en 98 c'était la première fois depuis
fin pour ce club là en tous les cas
depuis 90 ans depuis 1908 et en 99 la
Coupe de France et là vous êtes parti
pour vous occuper de l'équipe de France
donc vous êtes ça vous a flippé quoi eh
je crois que c'est difficile de refuser
même si c'est vrai que j'ai quitté le
Stade Français SSG avec beaucoup de avec
beaucoup d'émotions parce que je vous ai
parti vous êtes rentrés chez vous vous
êtes mis au lit vous êtes chialer vous
dites comme un gosse ouais non mais le
dernier match avec mes joueurs ou
j'avais l'occasion de leur parler que le
dernier briefing parce que c'est vrai
que l'entraîneur c'est toujours
sympa de parler avec ses joueurs de les
motiver et puis le jour où on a perdu en
plus en Irlande et que je savais que
c'était mon dernier entretien puisque un
nouvel entraîneur allait être nommé mais
c'est vrai que j'ai craqué quand je suis
rentré des trucs je me suis dit j'en
plus jamais je leur parlerai j'avais
l'impression de quitter une famille quoi
vous avez un conseiller formidable c'est
votre fils quoi
oui c'est vrai
combat
castanière je vais te la faire moi ton
équipe de France et tout il a 9 ans
le 10 mai c'est vrai que pour lui c'est
facile quoi ok il a mis de sélectionner
mec avec qui il vous aide
c'est mon verre
changer de PLACE Vanessa vous serez
mieux
je rigole attention
on rigole toi c'est dans ta chambre
[Rires]
je vous salue je peux aller vous fallait
vous coucher oui c'est sûr parce que
demain une grosse journée encore
on sera tous là
ils sont en jaune aussi quand vous allez
faire qui c'est qui va changer le
maillot
celui-ci je pense je sais pas
maintenant nous je pense qu'on va
regarder nos couleurs
ils sont peut-être indulgent d'accord on
espère torse cette nuit il fait beau
merci beaucoup et bravo et le 7 mai donc
au Stade de France
salut
[Applaudissements]
toute façon et je vais accueillir la
personne qui va venir l'occuper c'est à
mon sens le plus grand écrivain français
du moment c'est Michel Houellebecq
bonsoir merci d'être là bonsoir tout le
monde vous arrivez de vacances là vous
êtes bronzés non non c'est le maquillage
enfin si j'étais en vacances mais je
suis pas bronzé
je fais des trucs nouveaux donc c'est
toujours des soucis
tout le monde ici connaît Michel
Houellebecq en tous les cas cette année
formidable d'abord il avait écrit un
bouquin qui s'appelait extension du
domaine de la lutte qui était adapté au
cinéma d'ailleurs par Philippe elle
ensuite il a fait les particules
élémentaires qui est un roman
extrêmement important et que je vous
conseille de lire si vous l'avez déjà
fait ça s'est vendu quoi 300 000
exemplaires oui bon il y a encore donc
quelques millions de gens qui peuvent
l'acheter ça a été traduit en 25 langues
ce qui prouve que a priori il y a
quelque chose
ça devait être adapté au cinéma par
Pierrelatte c'est pas fait ça non
ça va être adapté au cinéma mais je sais
pas par qui alors les particuliers
élémentaires donc voilà vous pouvez
l'acheter
vous publiez vous avez publié en
septembre Renaissance donc vous dites en
passez d'un recueil de poésie et vous
dites en parlant de renaissance je vais
profiter de ma zoom zoum mon garçon
dites je vais profiter de ma nouvelle
notoriété pour et sortir de essayer de
sortir la poésie de son ghetto
bah tout le monde oui oui dès qu'on
beaucoup de gens ont essayé ouais
moi j'essaye je suis pas le premier mais
vous avez trouvé un système en tous les
cas pour sortir la poésie de son ghetto
mais Michel c'est que vous avez fait un
CD ben oui
c'est une bonne formule à faire de la
musique en même temps quand on trouve la
musique qui va ça peut pas arriver à
chaque fois mais là vous allez trouver
qu'ici les musiques et ça va être votre
votre présence au Printemps de Bourges
va être le 20 avril sans doute
l'événement du Printemps de Bourges
en fait c'est une vachement bonne idée
de mettre des poèmes en musique ce qui
est plus délicat c'est l'idée que
j'interprète moi-même mais ça c'est
parce qu'on n'a pas trouvé donc s'il y a
un interprète
quelconque à l'écoute
alors
[Musique]
cette chanson je peux l'écouter en
boucle non mais j'aime beaucoup Vanessa
mais mais je sais pas si j'ai écrit des
trucs bien pour pour les filles quoi
pour pour écouter un petit bout de Playa
Blanca
[Musique]
sur le palmier mort
salut et la soirée des codiacles
[Musique]
comme une enclave qui chante au milieu
du monde qui souffle
[Musique]
sans entrave
incroyable mais vrai c'est Michel
Houellebecq l'auteur des particules
élémentaires qui chantent comme quoi
tout est possible tout est possible tout
est possible oui mais j'aimerais bien
aussi
le 20 avril le Printemps de Bourges
enfin on va essayer que ça soit bien
c'est plus sûr on met fin mais là
le 20 très bien mais à Lyon transbordeur
Angoulême Toulouse Bordeaux Rennes vous
faites toute une tournée Monaco voilà
bah oui là ça devrait mettre le plaisir
porter dans la littérature on vous
souhaite le même succès dans le disque
parce que votre bouquin est sorti comme
ça d'un seul coup ça a été je me
souviens la rentrée 98 les particules
élémentaires c'était le livre ça l'est
toujours d'ailleurs on en parle toujours
au moins une fois par semaine ah ouais
une fois par semaine
avec le recul Michel Houellebecq comment
vous réagissez aujourd'hui comment vous
considérez les les polémiques qui ont
suivi la parution des particules
élémentaires chez Flammarion
mais mais c'est bien qu'il y ait des
polémiques en France c'est un pays
sympathique pour ça enfin il y a des
polémiques sur des livres il y a une
polémique dans votre livre enfin je vais
pas raconter votre livre parce que c'est
ni le jour ni l'heure mais disons qu'il
y avait plusieurs thèmes et notamment
une critique des mœurs libérales et des
dérives laxistes de Mai 68 qui est un
peu le enfin le thème c'est bien qu'il y
a pas de critique du film la parenthèse
enchantée où joue Clotilde de Kourou
avec Vincent Elbaz Géraldine paillasse
Karine Viard
voilà l'exemple même
Michel l'exemple même alors d'un enfant
de 68 là depuis depuis le début de la
soirée on arrive pas à la tenir on sent
bien qu'elle a été qu'elle a été élevée
par des parents Bamako là c'est évident
parce que lui il a bien parlé de ça dans
son bouquin les sages là elle est sage
depuis que vous êtes là elle est sage
les enfants sont débrouillés comme ils
pouvaient exactement vous avez vous avez
choqué d'abord en disant ça parce que
c'est vrai que c'était la première fois
ou un auteur un écrivain disait
critiquer 68 en disant Charles Manson ça
aurait pas été possible 168 donc d'un
coup ça mit tout le monde devant ses
responsabilités voilà je caricature un
peu mais c'est ça l'esprit mais ça à
peine malheureusement ouais à peine
malheureusement c'est vous disiez en
dans votre bouquin puis dans les
interviews je vous ai donné par la suite
que finalement 68 c'était surtout pour
vous le triomphe de l'industrie du
divertissement oui mais je maintiens
mais c'est
façon quand on dit un truc pour la
première fois on peut toujours
s'attendre les ennuis le mec qui a dit
que la terre classique il a eu des
emmerdes aussi
et puis alors il y avait aussi dans
votre bouquin ce qui a choqué les gens
c'est que c'est la première fois qu'on
décrivait des scènes érotiques non
satisfaisantes parce que habituellement
dans les dans les films érotiques dans
les livres érotiques tout le monde jouit
tout le monde est content et vous vous
avez vous avez parlé de la sexualité
avec réalise non ouais mais elles sont
pas non satisfaisantes non plus sur ces
moyens que c'est comme la réalité quoi
c'est comme dans la vie il y a du
satisfaisant et du pas satisfaisant
parce que c'est vrai que c'est
c'est pas de l'érotisme de la sexualité
réaliste
c'est toujours vachement bien tout le
monde est content en fait le truc je
vais vous dire dites-moi Michel le grand
secret
dans l'histoire c'est que la le point
culminant des scènes n'est pas la
sexualité dans mes scènes c'est que ça
continue après donc la sexualité un
moment qu'intervient au milieu
c'est pas une fin en soi quoi
parce que dans tous les films qui soient
porno ou sentimentaux ça finit toujours
par le poil plus sexuel alors que moi je
continue après
les gens continuent à parler après et
donc sexualité est intégrée dans dans
une narration
vous avez une réflexion sur les films
porno vous dites que dans les années 70
les actrices de film porno étaient moins
jolies qu'aujourd'hui à quoi c'est dû à
votre avis ça c'est simple c'est parce
que maintenant tout le monde accepte de
faire des films porno donc il y a plus
de concurrence donc c'est les plus
belles qui ont le alors que dans les
années 70 c'est celle qui voulait un peu
qui les tourne
donc effectivement les films porno sont
devenus moins réalistes du coup parce
que les filles sont plus jolies quoi
est-ce qu'il y a beaucoup choqué les
gens donc il y a eu effectivement cette
critique de 68 il y a eu cette façon de
raconter la sexualité d'une façon très
quotidienne comme ça très réel et bien
aussi toutes les mutations du corps
humain par exemple vous dites vous enfin
c'est pas dans le bouquin mais vous
dites dans les interviews moi l'idée
d'un seul sexe ne semble pas mal ça
serait bien qu'on ait des clitoris et
des glands un peu partout sur le corps
comme ça ça serait des capteurs de
plaisir il y a plein d'idées mais vous
avez plein non mais vous avez quand même
ça aussi c'est bizarre c'est
l'introduction
dans les Michelle c'est vrai c'est
l'introduction de la science-fiction
dans le roman
mais ça
non mais c'est fou non mais j'ai
beaucoup
malheureusement je suis désolé moi j'ai
beaucoup choqué
j'ai beaucoup choqué parce que moi
j'étais pas contre les mutations
génétiques et donc le
tous les trucs
génétique bizarre qu'on fait moi je
trouve que vous êtes pas contre le
clonage
inéluctable clonage et qui finira toute
façon le clonage humain finira par
exemple et donc ça finira par s'imposer
comme mode de reproduction je pense
alors on vous a accusé ce qui est
incroyable c'est comme vous accusez de
véhiculer des fantasmes eugéniques et
totalitaire alors que vous vous placez
la compassion au dessus de toutes les
qualités humaines quelqu'un vraiment
compassionnel bah oui houellebec à 20
ans il a mis un coup de pied un pigeon
et il dit c'est ce que j'ai fait de plus
méchant dans ma vie et je m'en veux
encore oui sympa mais oui j'ai pas fait
j'ai pas fait pire
il en souffre toujours mais oui ce
pauvre pigeon je sais pas c'était une
femme
c'est un geste de poste post délinquant
je sais pas pourquoi les bons c'est vrai
que les pigeons de temps en temps il y
en a beaucoup c'est agaçant à Paris je
sais pas qui qui est de la Mairie de
Paris c'est Monsieur Blade
a fait scandale et pour la bonne cause
je dirais en revanche il y a eu un
scandale si vous n'ayez pas le le prix
Goncourt quoi
que vous n'avez pas eu vous avez dit mon
éditeur en l'occurrence la Marion
n'avait pas de ligne budgétaire pour
acheter les jurés bah oui
mais ça c'est pas un scoop enfin bon il
paraît que c'est un scoop qu'un écrivain
de dise c'est la première fois qu'un
écrivains le dire donc j'avais pas
l'impression de dire un truc si choquant
que ça je croyais que c'est tout le
monde tout le monde le savait déjà quoi
comme ça c'est à dire qu'il leur demande
une préface et au lieu de leur payer la
préface 5000 francs il leur paye la
préface 50000 francs enfin j'ai dit ça
un peu imprudemment mais je pensais que
tout le monde le savait maintenant bah
non enfin tout le monde le savait
personne le disait
alors il y a une chose pour terminer
avec vous Michel Houellebecq qui vous
resterez au-delà de tout ça comme le
premier qui a dénoncé l'inégalité
sexuelle c'est-à-dire qu'on avait déjà
dénoncé toutes les formes d'inégalités
et vous vous avez été le premier là
aussi à dire un peu comme pour le
concours mettez le premier à dire que la
compétition sexuelle est plus sauvage
que la compétition que la compétition
capitaliste et qu'en fait il y a aucune
loi dans ce domaine tous les coups sont
permis c'est la loi du plus fort ça
aussi c'est quelque chose qui était le
premier à énoncer c'est en fait la vraie
compétition c'est la compétition
sexuelle et celle là il y a pas
d'égalité possible en plus ben non je
suis désolé d'avoir renoncé cette chose
déprimante mais je n'ai rien à retranche
bah oui je sais ouais c'est plus tard
évidemment il y a les clubs échangistes
ça c'est le communisme sexuel c'est le
faut déjà voilà c'est le club échangiste
mais enfin tu es alors la compétition en
revanche c'est la
discothèque c'est la compétition c'est
dur mais faut pas c'est vrai que
on est samedi vers une heure du matin là
il y a probablement des gens qui
rentrent déprimés
en train de regarder
c'est fini c'est fini
vous êtes au courant j'ai pas envie de
bouger c'est chaud ça va
[Applaudissements]
je vais faire une interview fin du monde
comme vous êtes quelqu'un de
spécialement gay comme on vient de le
voir
une interview fin du monde alors c'est
la fin du monde Michel oui les corbeaux
c'est la fin du monde si vous deviez
sauver un livre moi je prendrai la Bible
parce que bon c'est pas abouti
mais on peut en refaire plein à partir
de la Bible donc c'est très générateur
quoi il y a plein de petites histoires
on peut déjà beaucoup servi pour refaire
des livres à partir de si vous deviez
sauver un animal ou bichon frisé le
bichon frisé oui vous aimez les bichons
frisés oui c'est magnifique on va votre
grand-mère avait un bichon frisé
un tout petit chien c'est comme une
peluche c'est tout gentil
ça boit pas beaucoup non presque pas
c'est hyper gentil
si vous deviez sauver une idée une idée
hausse je vais être un peu chiant c'est
peut-être l'idée de la preuve
mathématique ça c'est bien ça a beaucoup
un disque
il y en a trop le vôtre non non
Beethoven c'est mieux
un film peut-être murno l'horreur
si vous aviez sauvé un sexe
je veux dire ça se pose même pas
moi je dirais le tabac ça a l'air de
rien mais c'est bien si vous deviez
sauver un homme politique ça serait qui
honnêtement j'aime bien Chevènement mais
désolé désolé pour le public
mais non j'aime bien Chevènement
Chevènement ah ouais ouais je trouve
qu'il est court un jeu qui l'a sauvé une
fois il avait écouté pierre aussi
nous allons passer à attention
tout le monde se concentre nous allons
passer à la grande épreuve de l'émission
[Musique]
alors j'espère que Jade j'espère que
Khan n'a pas eu les réponses
donc c'est un spécial c'est un spécial
amour
comme il y avait Sébastien on s'est dit
puis il y a bled c'est des gens d'amour
donc on s'est dit on va faire un spécial
amour vous êtes prêtes il faut
reconnaître les morceaux à la première
étape
contre les
gens ouais c'est un jeu c'est un blind
test
révélation
deuxième chanson de Didier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est Sébastien Sébastien il a tellement
passé dans ses émissions Montagnac
pour Sébastien un point pour cadre
troisième chanson Didier
4e chance
[Musique]
merci Didier ok je t'aime donc ça fait
quand même
son fils et son fils il fait rien papa
un bateau et Jennifer
comment ça s'écrit tu as raison c'est un
bateau
oui mais c'est Sébastien qui a trouvé
oui c'est moi
qui est chez lui et que ça bière sur son
canapé avec son pétard bah cher ami
téléspectateurs c'est Sébastien qui a
trouvé chanson écrite par Jean Renard
5e chanson
[Musique]
merci Didier alors là je sais pas
combien il a de points Sébastien
love me please
attention chanson numéro 7
[Musique]
ouais bravo vanille
un point donc pour Vanessa de moins que
je fais ici bravo
chanson numéro 8 Didier
Lara Fabian
Lara
Fabian
alors maintenant je vais vous faire le
super banco il y a deux chansons super
banco dur donc je suis qui les trouve
bas le gagnant d'accord c'est le super
bon c'est pas du jeu très très dur c'est
pas dur chanson suivante
révélation d'initier sera plus vite
je crois que tu
en veux
d'être aussi belle preuve c'est Jacques
Duval ah oui à midi
Sacha Distel a fait la version française
il a pas de cheveux soyez gentil
avec lui ces quatre qui a gagné bravo
a embrassez-le on lui avait promis on
avait dit si tu gagnes elle t'embrassera
allez juste
[Musique]
on peut rallumer
ouais ouais
bien merci c'était donc tout le monde en
parle donc Patrick Sébastien thème le 26
avril en salle
Clotilde Courau dans la parenthèse
enchantée le 26 avril et de rire malado
mis en scène par Savary le lendemain le
27 Michel Houellebecq présence humaine
chez Tricatel
vanessa Demouy bientôt le marquis et
Bernard Blade le feuilleton de la Mairie
de Paris voilà c'était tout le monde en
parle rendez-vous la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu